Oh Leute, ich habe mir gedacht, heute Abend kein Kreiselgrind und wenn heute Abend kein Kreiselgrind, dann kann ich einfach mal den Stream anmachen, ohne dass ich mir großartig was im Vorfeld überlegt habe.
Ich muss ja seit der Woche wieder arbeiten, das ist geistig echt anstrengend, nicht weil es die Woche so viel zu machen gibt, sondern einfach die Umstellung von ganzen Tag Kreiselgrind zu man muss wieder was machen für sein Geld.
Ich hatte kein Problem damit 24-7 MMO Kreiselgrind zu machen und dafür bezahlt zu werden.
Also im gleichen Umfang wie jetzt.
Null Viewer, aber mehrstens 5, 6.
Das schwankt immer, das ist sehr weird auf Twitch teilweise.
Und manchmal dauert es auch ein paar Minuten, bis tatsächlich Notifications und so verschickt werden, aber da bin ich schon dran gewöhnt.
Und ähnlich habe ich auch ein bisschen.
Seit gestern Abend habe ich auch ein bisschen Kopfweh.
Ich hoffe nicht, dass ich ernsthaft mich am ersten Tag in Frankfurt gleich mit Corona oder irgendeinem Kack wieder angesteckt habe.
Das hatte ich einmal, das brauche ich nicht wieder.
Das war richtig Kacke, da war ich drei Wochen im Arsch.
Sadge.
Wie war die erste Woche?
Die ist ja noch nicht rum.
Die ist ja noch nicht rum, aber bis jetzt war ganz okay.
War nicht viel los.
War nicht, war nicht viel los.
Wie war bei euch die erste Woche?
Also es war nicht viel los.
Wie gesagt, ich habe nur festgestellt, ich habe komplett verlernt mit Leuten zu reden.
Nachdem ich jetzt einen Monat Kreiselgrind gemacht habe, sind meine Social Skills noch schlechter als vorher schon.
Wir haben irgendwann Ende des Monats ein Team-Event Neujahrsessen.
Da muss ich noch gucken, wie ich das am besten absage.
Das ist mir zu spät.
Und außerdem habe ich auf abendliche Team-Events irgendwie auch keinen Bock.
Kennt mich, bin ich so social.
Okay.
Lieber MMO-Kreiselgrind machen.
Verstehe mich mit den Leuten gut, daran liegt es nicht.
Ich habe trotzdem keinen Bock.
1 bis 21 Uhr an einem Mittwoch oder so sogar.
Mittwoch 21 Uhr in Frankfurt.
Nee, das ist nix.
Mittagessen würdest du mit mir reden lassen?
Mr. SN Alive.
Dankeschön für den Snap.
Pog.
Er braucht schon Social Skills.
Ja, ich glücklich.
Ich habe das nicht so viel.
Ah, nee.
Ich finde das nicht schlimm.
Ich habe aber gemerkt, dass ich...
Moment, warte mal.
Ich mache mal kurz hier andere Musik an.
Nee.
Ich mache mal die VM an und Package Updates.
Was wollte ich jetzt gerade sagen?
Das...
Ach so, ja.
Gut, ich habe gemerkt, dass ich mich egal, wie man es dreht und wendet,
einfach im Office selbst nicht so gut konzentrieren kann, wie daheim.
Gar nicht so sehr, dass man sich da vorne nehmen würde.
Ich mache jetzt nix.
Sondern man kann sich einfach nicht so gut konzentrieren.
Da hast du irgendwelche Leute, die telefonieren.
Irgendwelche Leute, die dich fragen.
Sei es, dass du selbst irgendwo mal irgendwie so dein Ohr dranhängen willst oder so.
Deswegen mag ich persönlich auch Wechselarbeitsplätze.
Ich sitze ja lieber auf Wechselarbeitsplätzen als am eigentlichen Platz im Büro.
Da bin ich auch ab und zu mal.
Aber da weiß ich, wenn da irgendjemand da ist, dann bin ich da.
Wenn man telefoniert, ist nix, was man irgendwie was mitkriegen muss.
Ich finde es auch im eigenen Teambüro immer ein bisschen doof,
da Noise-Canceling-Kopfhörer anzuhaben.
Da kriegt man nix von mit.
Also mir ist...
Außerdem gefällt mir das mit dem Schreibtisch viel besser an Wechselarbeitsplätzen.
Ich mag Wechselarbeitsplätze.
Das ist ja ein Angeschied für den Sub.
Ich finde das nice.
Ich war da...
Ich war am Dienstag wieder in Frankfurt bei der Versicherung.
Hab mich an Wechselarbeitsplatz gehockt.
Zeug aufgebaut.
Mittags.
Alles für den Rucksack geschmissen und abgehauen.
Perfekt.
Und irgendwie...
Weiß nicht.
Irgendwie gibt es wenige Leute, die Wechselarbeitsplätze mögen.
Gut, das war auch der zweite Erste.
Am zweiten Ersten war natürlich nicht viel los.
Aber...
Da war halt sehr ruhig auch.
Warum gibt es
Whoop Arrive nicht mehr?
Ne, gibt es doch.
Der hat bei mir nur das E-Mode nicht angezeigt.
Wieso wenig Updates nur?
Was ist da los?
Ich habe drei Tage oder so nicht mehr geupdatet.
Anzeige ist raus.
Was ist hier?
Übrigens, Google ist ja auch wieder...
Ist ja wieder der Held, ne?
Google hat wieder Zeug umbenannt.
By the way, ich zeige euch das mal.
Falls ihr damit Probleme habt.
Google.
Google Cloud CLI SDK.
Die haben ihre Packages umbenannt.
Tja, findet man jetzt hier nicht.
Zumindest...
Zumindest es gibt...
Es gab ein Package, das nannte sich Google Cloud SDK.
So, das gibt es jetzt nicht mehr.
Es gibt jetzt das gleiche Package, nur anderer Name.
Google Cloud CLI.
Und die Dependencies haben sich geändert.
Aber die alten Packages, die sind dann nicht weg.
Du wunderst dich auf einmal beim Updaten, warum du irgendwelche File-Konflikte kriegst in deinem File-Manager.
Alter, was Google da teilweise wieder für Dinger macht, ist echt super weird.
Renamed.
Hier.
Wir haben unseren Set of Command-Strikes renamed.
Developer-Tools.
Google CLI to make...
Ja.
Das heißt jetzt...
Genau, das heißt jetzt nicht mehr...
Cloud SDK, sondern Cloud CLI.
Alles klar.
Man konnte das natürlich auch nicht unter gleichem Namen lassen, obviously.
Wäre ja ein Unding, wenn das einfach weiterhin Google Cloud SDK heißen würde.
Ja, stimmt, stimmt.
Ja, das war die Woche eh das Beste.
Auf jedem Meeting, überall, haben sie sich...
Wo ist Neues und wie seid ihr gerutscht?
Haha.
Haben sich wieder alle gefreut.
Ich meine, die meisten Leute meinen das nett.
Die wissen ja nicht, dass ich so ein unsozialer Kackspaß bin, denen das nervt, wenn die Leute nett sein wollen.
Diese Leute wollen ja nett sein.
Ich versuche dann auch immer nett zu sein.
Letztens fand ich witzig, hatten wir es von Teilzeitarbeiten und da habe ich halt gemeint,
ich mache das jetzt, glaube ich, schon 2013 oder so.
Und ich kann das echt nur empfehlen.
Und da wurde ich dann gefragt, ja, warum ich Teilzeit arbeiten würde, wegen den Kindern, oder warum?
Ich meine, nee, ich habe mich noch nicht weiter...
Ich habe mich noch nicht geforkt.
Ich habe mich noch nicht fortgepflanzt.
Nicht wegen der Kinder.
So.
Ich sehe wahrscheinlich mittlerweile echt so Dad-mäßig aus vom Alter her, so Vater-mäßig aus, auch vom Alter her und allem.
Vielen Dank für den Sub.
Gamepad auch am Start.
Der Schmoll-Axis-Point.
Pock.
Danke, Leute, für die ganzen Subs.
Nee, nicht wegen den Kindern.
Deswegen habe ich keine Teilzeit angefangen.
Ihr wisst warum.
Ihr seid ein Teil davon.
Weshalb ich mit Teilzeit...
Unbewusst, weshalb ich mit Teilzeit angefangen habe.
Eigentlich benutze ich den aktuellen Montag eher zum Abgammeln noch einen Tag weiter,
anstatt dass ich ernsthaft was für YouTube und Twitch machen würde.
Aber so ist es halt.
Ja, so muss es sein.
Bam.
Ich meine, warum nicht?
Ich finde das vollkommen in Ordnung.
Ich würde es auch nicht an die große Glocke hängen.
Jetzt kommen wir noch auf die Idee, mich nicht einzustellen.
Das sind ja zwei Fragen in einem.
Also, das ist eine schwierige Frage.
Also, den ersten Teil der Frage kann ich einfach beantworten.
Nee, habe ich nicht.
Den zweiten Teil der Frage, der ist in der Tat enorm schwierig zu beantworten.
Denn, ihr habt ja so die ein oder anderen Sachen im Stream schon mitgekriegt.
Und in...
99% der Fälle ist es ja immer daran gescheitert, weil ich mich um nichts gekümmert habe.
Ihr kennt ja die ein oder andere Story.
Also, und ihr kennt mich mittlerweile auch.
Für mich sind soziale Interaktionen immer sehr...
Belastend ist das falsche Wort.
Anstrengend.
Und das führt meistens dazu, dass...
Dass, wenn sich etwas anbahnt, beziehungsweise anbahnen könnte,
ich das direkt versuche zu vermeiden.
So, und...
Das läuft dann auf so Dinger raus, wie...
Erinnert sich noch einer an das Weihnachtsgrill von vor...
Boah, wann war das?
Das war noch vor Corona.
Wo ich euch das mal erzählt habe, ne?
Wo wir uns sogar schon kleine Sachen zu Weihnachten geschenkt haben.
Was man ja nicht einfach random macht.
Und was habe ich gemacht?
Ich habe mir sogar was Nettes zum Weihnachten...
Als Weihnachtsgeschenk überlegt.
Und was habe ich gemacht?
Da hat sich auch super drüber gefreut.
Ich habe mich nie wieder gemeldet.
Einfach random.
Ich habe nie wieder...
Und alles...
Alles immer umschifft so.
Weil ich halt sozialmäßig der übelste Kackschmast bin.
Ich habe euch das ja schon erzählt.
Also...
Es ist...
Ja, ist halt so.
Jetzt.
Nach vier Jahren ist klar.
Ey.
Übrigens.
Vor vier Jahren, ne?
Aber nee, mache ich nicht.
Weil es hat ja seinen Grund gehabt.
Vier Jahre, nicht vier Monate, vier Wochen.
Vier Jahre.
Das ist das, was ich euch erzählt hatte damals.
Mit den...
Mit den Schuhen.
Vielleicht erinnert ihr euch noch.
Ich meine...
Gut.
Ich gehe nicht davon aus, dass das Zeug, was ich hier blödes Zeug labere, sich überhaupt noch irgendjemand daran erinnert nach vier Jahren.
Wo ich das eigentlich mit den Schuhen...
Bist du damit ein...
Ja.
Ich bin unglücklich, wenn ich viele soziale Kontakte habe.
Das ist es ja.
Ich weiß nicht.
Das ist bestimmt irgendeine Krankheit oder so.
Keine Ahnung.
Wahrscheinlich.
Wahrscheinlich ist das irgendwer...
Hat irgendeinen super komplizierten lateinischen Namen oder so.
Ja.
Nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein.
Nein, habe ich nicht.
Also ganz so schlimm war das jetzt auch nicht.
Also ich habe ja nicht einfach...
Ich habe ja nicht einfach so nach dem Motto...
Ah, guck mal, eine Message.
Ach, löschen und nicht mal...
Nein, nein, nein.
Ich habe aber nichts in der Richtung mehr unternommen so.
Ich habe nicht wirklich geantwortet von mir.
Also mit irgendwelchen...
Ja.
Weiteren Versuchen.
Im Prinzip war ich happy, dass sie sich darüber gefreut hat.
Und wisst ihr...
Ich meine, ihr müsst euch mal überlegen, ja.
Wenn eine Frau...
Einem ein wehrer Tor...
Torx...
Schraubendreher-Set schenkt.
Das ist eigentlich schon ein sehr positives Signal.
Also, dass sie...
Schon...
Schon Plan hat.
Ja.
Random Leute, die keine Ahnung haben, schenken irgendein...
Irgendein komisches Zeugs vom Aldi oder so.
Ein wehrer Torx-Schraubendreher-Set.
Das habe ich übrigens immer noch hier am Start.
Und ich habe ihr ein paar...
Ein paar...
Schuhe...
Schuhe geschenkt.
Weil...
Mädels haben ja immer kalte Füße.
Und so.
Und dann...
Ich habe ihr ein paar Schuhe geschenkt.
Mit...
So...
Was ist da drin?
So Lavendel-Mischung oder so.
Die kann man in die Mikrowelle...
Die kann man in die Mikrowelle legen.
Und dann...
Werden die warm.
Und dann hat man irgendwie 45 Minuten warme Füße oder sowas.
Ja.
Das dachte ich mir schon, dass das gut ankommt.
Und...
Kam auch gut an.
Ja.
Und...
Ich...
Ich kann das nicht erklären.
Das ist ganz merkwürdig.
Sobald ich merke...
Nicht immer.
Aber...
Sobald ich merke, dass es auf...
Real-Life-Soziale-Interaktion rausläuft...
Versuche ich das immer zu umgehen.
Och.
Was jetzt?
Vodafone.
Was? Oh fuck.
Was war das...
Was war das letzte, was ihr gehört habt?
Also...
Ich habe im Endeffekt nur gesagt...
Sobald es...
Sobald es auf...
Relife-Interaktion...
Eh...
Auf Relife-Interaktion rausgeht.
Auf...
Auf soziale Relife-Interaktion...
Rausläuft.
Dann versuche ich das immer zu umgehen.
Irgendwie zu vermeiden.
Das ist nicht so, dass ich nicht mit Leuten gut klarkommen würde.
Ich glaube...
Ich glaube, die meisten Leute, mit denen ich mich so...
Jo...
Mit denen ich mich...
Mit denen ich mich so...
so da
die finden das
ich denke nicht, dass die denken, ich bin der übelste Depp oder so
ich glaube, die meisten Leute finden mich da
ganz nett, aber ich habe halt so
null Interesse an großartigen Socials
außer mit ein paar Leuten
mit ein paar Leuten muss ich sagen
mit ein paar mit denen verstehe ich mich echt gut
mit denen, da
rede ich auch gerne und viel so, aber es gibt halt
nicht so viele
auf der alten Arbeit hatte ich
so 1, 2 mit denen ich öfters geschwätzt habe
auf der neuen Arbeit habe ich auch so 1, 2
mit denen ich öfters schwätze
privat kenne ich auch so, auch 1, 2
das reicht aber, das ist dann schon komplett
ausreichend für mich
was mich
an Menschenansammlungen
stört ist, also ich habe kein Problem
irgendwie auf eine Messe zu gehen
oder sonst was
keiner von mir
der hat ja so richtige, wie nennt man das
so Menschenansammlungssozialphobie
oder sowas
der meint, der fängt immer voll an zu schwitzen
der wird nervös, das Problem
habe ich nicht, was mich
also mich nerven nicht große Menschenansammlungen
mich nerven
große
Gesprächsrunden
wo es
darum geht, dass
jeder jetzt möglichst
penetrant erzählen muss
warum er der Tollste in der Runde ist
so, wisst ihr wie ich meine
das ist ja so, gibt es bestimmte Namen
für das gewisse Soziales
Phänomen ist das ja, wenn die Leute
mehrere Leute auf dem Haufen stehen
und
am besten auch, wenn die sich noch
nur so am Rande kennen
da muss jeder erstmal loslassen
warum er der Geilste ist
dann kommt der Nächste wieder an und erzählt
das fuckt mich immer so ab, ich denke mir immer so
Alter, warum stehst du denn da überhaupt dabei, es interessiert mich überhaupt nicht
ja
also, so sieht es aus
ne, also wie gesagt
um das abschließend zu beantworten
ich bin
ich bin happy damit, umso mehr
soziale Kontakte ich habe, umso unglücklicher
bin ich, also insofern ist alles gut
der Twitch-Chat zählt zum Glück nicht
als sozialer Kontakt, ja
und auf die Sache hier nochmal
zurückzukommen mit 4 Jahren, ja
da muss ich
jetzt auch nicht mehr, außerdem hat es ja
seinen Grund, das wäre jetzt auch nicht realistisch
betrachtet, wäre
das jetzt auch nicht anders, es hat ja
seinen Grund gehabt, es ist nicht so, dass ich mich
damals gar nicht mehr gemeldet habe, aber ich habe also über
überhaupt keine Anstalten mehr gemacht
das irgendwie weiter
zu verfolgen, ja
ich habe dann immer nur kurz darauf geantwortet
wahrscheinlich hat sie dann
darauf gewartet, dass ich mich dann auch mal rühre
und sowas, ja
und das ist dann so immer so
wo man sich
am Anfang da öfters
nochmal geschrieben hat
war jetzt dann halt immer weniger
und irgendwie so nach 1-2 Wochen gar nicht mehr
und ich habe dann auch nicht mehr geschrieben, so
also insofern, zumindest auch
eine Sache werde ich nie wieder machen
das kann ich euch sagen
das habe ich, das habe ich
durch
keine Mädels mehr in MMOs kennenlernen
haha, das ist vorbei Leute
das mache ich
nicht mehr
ich kann mich noch daran erinnern, zu meiner
MMO-Crime-Zeit
von, keine Ahnung
bis 2007 oder so
das war so anstrengend
ja
ich habe damals
geht es um die Festival-Mädelsgeschichte?
nein, nein, um die geht es nicht
also Mädels rein
online ist nichts für mich
also wirklich nur die Leute
rein online kennenlernen
und sich da irgendwie dann ein paar Wochen
nur schreiben und so, da malt man sich
immer von den anderen Leuten was aus
was sie gar nicht sind
das ist echt das Problem
also wenn man, ich meine
ich bin ja realistisch, im Jahr
2024 ist es vollkommen normal
dass man Leute online
kennenlernt
und ähm
das sagen wir mal so, dass die
dass die Findung und die Kontaktaufnahme
so untereinander suchen, dass das online ist
keine Frage, ja, aber
das blöde ist dann
wenn du die Leute online kennenlernst, das heißt
in einem Game oder irgendeine App oder irgendeine Plattform
und wenn du dir dann wirklich nur Wochen und Monate
schreibst, da kommt
nichts bei rum
da kommt echt nichts bei rum
also ich hab da nur negative
Erfahrungen mitgemacht
selbst wenn man ab und zu telefoniert
und dann sagt, oh ja komm lass uns da mal irgendwie
in zwei Monaten bin ich dann in der Nähe
das bringt nichts Leute, glaubst du mir
das bringt nichts, das habe ich alles schon durch
das ist voll für den Arsch
man muss den Leuten schon mal
relativ zeitnah über den Weg laufen
damit man gleich mal abchecken kann
ob das denn theoretisch
nicht nur
Fantasiegebilde sind
die man sich da so zurecht tippt
das ist wirklich ein bisschen
weil selbst, mein ernsthaft
selbst wenn man sich online super versteht
miteinander telefoniert
sich in der Webcam schon gesehen hat, Bilder
und man sich dann auch gegenseitig ganz
hübsch findet und passt alles
es ist echt ein Unterschied, wenn man die Leute vor Ort sieht
ich rede jetzt nicht
von gefakten Instagram Bildern oder sowas
es ist einfach ein Unterschied
es gibt Leute, da denkt man sich, ey die sind ganz nett
den läufst du offline über den Weg
und denkst dir, boah ey
mit dem oder der halte ich es aber
keine 20 Minuten zusammen
hier im Raum aus
das ist kacke, das funktioniert nicht
man muss sich da schon relativ zeitnah
sich was überlegen
und wenn das dann so läuft
dass man sich denkt, okay
man findet sich auch offline
ganz sympathisch, dann ist das ja gut
aber rein online, nee
das kann es klingen
ja
nee, aber wie gesagt, nicht Festival
gut, wie dem auch sei
komplett random Thema, ich weiß
hattest du mal eine Frage mit deiner Jugend
beantwortet oder war da genau
das Internet weg, welche Frage
mit meiner Jugend?
achso hier, das habe ich gar nicht gesehen
was ist das aus?
Moment, ich muss mal kurz die Musik umschalten
das war eigentlich nur fürs Intro gedacht
das läuft jetzt zum fünften Mal oder so schon durch
aber irgendwie, was haben wir denn sonst noch
hier irgendwie, ja hier, wupp wupp wupp
perfekt, wupp wupp wupp
also
Lüge verfolgt
Lügenstraften, Terrorfinanzierung
jetzt auch noch
was
der lässt aber nichts aus oder
oder ist das einfach nur CheBated Überschrift
okay, aber zu deiner Frage Profi Harzer
da frage ich dich auch mal vorher was
Profi Harzer
ist der Name Programm oder einfach nur Just for Fun
Warst du in deiner Jugend auch so
und hattest du damals
vielleicht noch mehr, dass dich zu verstellen
ja hatte ich
ja also ich war schon schon eigentlich immer so aber das ja das hatte ich da habe ich sogar
ein video zugemacht glaube ich ja also ich hatte relativ lange das bedürfnis so sachen
zu machen wie zum beispiel auf die weihnachtsfeier gehen und oder irgendwie irgendwelche veranstaltung
oder sowas und und ich hatte damals schon keinen bock aber ich bin dann hin weil ich mir immer
gedacht habe ja so sieht doch doof aus oder dass das gehört sich doch dahin zu gehen und so was
oder auch versucht habe irgendwie bisschen mit leuten die mir eigentlich am arsch vorbeigehen
zu smalltalken und so was ja ja das habe ich relativ lang probiert ja das habe ich relativ
lang probiert und habe mir eigentlich nichts ich habe mir da gar nichts großartig bei gedacht ich
dachte mir eigentlich das ist für alle so anstrengend wisst ihr wie ich mein
soll so nach dem motto ich habe eigentlich gedacht es geht allen so aber irgendwann habe
irgendwann bin ich aber auf die idee gekommen so nachdem also wenn das wirklich allen so gehen
würde dann würde ich ja wird das ja alles nicht funktionieren da wird ja keine anfangen von sich
aus ja also das habe ich probiert von weihnachtsfeier bis geburtstag bis sonstwas also ist eigentlich
schon sehr lang also in meiner jugend war das auf jeden fall wo ich noch viel kleiner war war es
noch nicht ganz so schlimm zweiter da war ich auch ich war bei den pfadfindern im verein
und so was da ging das eigentlich noch aber selbst da habe ich schon gemerkt dass ich relativ wenig
bock drauf hatte auf größere soziale sachen ja keine ahnung psychologie was neurowissenschaftler
psychologie solange du keinen leidensdruck verspürst ist auch kein grund zur änderung
ist keine krankheit aber gut krankheit nicht aber es gibt ja bestimmt eine bezeichnung für gibt ich
bin ja nicht der einzige darauf ist ja es gibt aber so ein paar widersprüchliche sachen ja da
muss ich jetzt auch mal sagen also kein bock auf soziale interaktion kontakte und feiern und und
smalltalk dinger heißt nicht zwangsläufig dass man ich meine ihr wisst dass ich das übelste kellerkind
schon immer gewesen bin immer vom rechner das heißt nicht zwangsläufig dass man wirklich
sprichwörtlich den ganzen tag im keller sitzen will es gibt so eine widersprüchliche sache die
ich mir zum beispiel bei mir auch nicht so richtig erklären kann und zwar ich habe überhaupt keinen
freund auf soziale interaktion und ich kann es mir auch nicht vorstellen wie das ist gibt ja leute
die haben irgendwie 30 30 40 freunde und die werden dann quasi jeden tag angerufen so nach dem motto
und karl kommst du heute noch vorbei wir machen diese und da so jawohl klar super und ach der
johnny ist auch da coolen habe ich schon ein halbes jahr nicht gesehen so es ist so wie
donnerstagabend 23 uhr leichter was ist mit euch los gibt es wirklich leute da bock drauf haben gut
Ja, sonst werden die Bars und alles nicht so voll.
Naja, zumindest auf sowas habe ich überhaupt keinen Bock.
Aber was mir wiederum gefällt ist, wenn ich irgendwas präsentieren kann oder so.
Das finde ich nice.
Also wenn ich mich irgendwie vorne hinstellen kann.
Das war es da nicht früher beispielsweise überhaupt keinen Bock drauf.
Also ganz, ganz früher noch in der Schule und so.
Aber das mache ich tatsächlich gerne.
Ich weiß nicht, wie das genau zusammenpasst.
Aber das liegt vielleicht auch daran, dass das keine soziale Interaktion und Smalltalk-Gelaber ist, wie das andere.
Sondern relativ themenspezifisch.
Und es ist ja keine Interaktion so eine Präsentation.
Wie auf irgendeiner Feier oder so.
Es geht ja im Prinzip darum, dass du deine Sache rüberbringst.
Die anderen müssen ja da nicht so.
Das ist ja sehr einseitig.
Natürlich muss man schon gucken, ob das gut ankommt und sowas.
Aber das mache ich tatsächlich gern.
Eventuell, weil du YouTube machst.
Ne, das war vorher auch schon so.
Aber YouTube hat auf jeden Fall was gebracht dazu.
Also YouTube hat auf jeden Fall was dazu gebracht.
Das habe ich euch ja auch schon oft erzählt.
Also wo YouTube auf jeden Fall was dazu gebracht hat, ist, wenn man so ein paar Hänger hat.
Also wenn der Kopf...
Wenn der Kopf gerade irgendwie Aussätze hat und du nicht genau weißt, wie es weitergeht.
Ich habe so ein paar Standardsprüche durch YouTube gelernt, die ich immer sage, wenn ich nicht weiter weiß.
Und mittlerweile kann ich die so gut auswendig.
Oder was heißt auswendig?
Mittlerweile kommen die schon so automatisch in den Redefluss mit rein,
dass man eigentlich gar nicht merkt, dass ich das gar nicht sagen wollte und etwas anderes,
etwas anderem weitermachen will.
Ja, was ich beispielsweise total oft sage ist,
ja und was man auch nicht vergessen darf oder, oder,
oder was man auch nicht vergessen darf,
was man auch dazu sagen muss.
Das sind so Sachen, die...
Wenn euch...
Müsst ihr mal auf meinen Videos...
Dann wisst ihr immer, wenn ihr das hört,
ich muss gerade kurz zwei Sekunden überlegen, was ich jetzt als nächstes sagen will.
Das sage ich total oft.
Hat bloß...
Das hat bloß auch keiner mitgekriegt.
Das ist meine...
Das ist mein Äh quasi.
Nicht, dass ich auch ab und zu mal Äh sagen würde.
Aber es gibt Leute, die sagen laufend Äh.
Ja, so oft sage ich es jetzt.
Es gibt Leute, die sagen laufend Äh.
Und ich habe anstatt Äh halt so...
Also...
Ein paar Übergangssätze, wo ich kurz nachdenken kann.
Das hat sich auf jeden Fall gelohnt durch YouTube.
Weil vorher hatte ich das nicht.
Und das ist auch eine Übungssache.
Aber ansonsten muss ich sagen.
Ehrlich, ich glaube nicht, dass YouTube jetzt das unbedingt großartig fördert.
Weil es ist schon ein Unterschied.
Jetzt überlegt euch mal.
Ihr steht auf der Arbeit vor 20 Leuten und müsst was präsentieren.
Oder...
Ihr sitzt vor 20 Leuten und müsst was präsentieren.
Oder ihr seid auf einem Computer.
Nehmt zeitversetzt was auf.
Das gucken sich dann 20.000, 30.000, 40.000, 50.000 Leute an.
Bei dem ersten kann sich, glaube ich, jeder reinversetzen, dass man ein bisschen nervös ist.
Allein schon, weil es direkt ist.
Du stehst da.
Die gucken dich an.
Und die erwarten jetzt auch, dass du was Gescheites von dir gibst.
So.
Versus Aufnahme, wo du weißt, irgendwann...
Das ist einfach was komplett anderes.
Also das...
Das...
Also...
Ich weiß nicht, ob es Leute gibt, die sagen, das bringt was, aber aus meiner Sicht bringt das nichts.
Livestream vielleicht schon ein bisschen mehr, aber auch nicht wirklich, weil du präsentierst ja nicht immer eines deiner Lieblingsthemen und vor allem ist ein Livestream auch nicht so fokussiert.
In 15 Minuten muss jetzt das Thema gut rübergebracht werden, sondern es ist, guckt euch das hier an, ich sitze einfach sinnlos vor meinem Recher und schwätze irgendwas ins Mikrofon, so könntest du keine Präsentation halten.
Die Leute würden jetzt schon pennen oder denken, Alter, was erzählt uns der Max da wieder eine halbe Stunde für einen Kack?
Was ihr euch wahrscheinlich sonntags morgens denkt, wenn ich eigentlich sage, wir gucken jetzt Videos und dann schaffen wir es in dreieinhalb Stunden wie letzten Sonntag, uns ein Viertelstunden Video anzugucken.
Alter, oder wie lang ging der Stream am Wochenende, wartet mal, Moment, ah, fuck, liegt, was, nein, ich hab die doch schon längst wieder abgeschaltet, die bringt keine Bestätigung, sie mal hinzuschicken.
Aufwachen-Stream, 3 Stunden 14, Leute, wir haben ein 20 Minuten, 15 oder 20 Minuten Video geguckt in der ganzen Zeit und eigentlich ist das ein Stream, so ein paar aktuelle Sachen anzugucken, GitHub-Trends und so ein paar YouTube-Videos zu gucken, wir haben genau ein Video geschafft.
Und ich hab...
Random, echt vom Hundertste ins Tausendste geschwätzt, so kannst du natürlich keine Präsentation halten.
Die pennen dir ein, die Leute, lass dich nie wieder was halten.
Aber das mach ich witzigerweise ganz gern.
Ich würde, ich würde das nicht unbedingt alles in einen Top schmeißen.
Das hört sich ein bisschen falsch an, dass in die, dass in diese Aufzählung noch Haustiere mit aufgenommen wurden von dir.
Jetzt einfach 20 Sekunden Delay.
Dann musst du, wenn du FFZ hast oder irgendein...
Irgendeins der Twitch-Plugins.
Alter!
Ich benutze den Account nicht und die E-Mail-Adresse ist längst abgeschaltet.
Twitch, geht mir nicht auf den Keks.
Ich bin Omega-Keckel.
Glaubt ihr ernsthaft, ich benutze das für irgendwas?
Das ist einfach hier als Streaming-Account, dass ich nicht aus Versehen irgendwas leake.
Naja.
Was wollte ich euch hier zeigen?
Keine Ahnung.
Ich lasse mich auch immer sehr gerne sidetracken und dann vergesse ich wieder die Hälfte.
Achso, ja hier.
20 Sekunden Delay.
Wenn du ein, wenn du beispielsweise FFZ installiert hast, da hast du hier so einen Knopf.
Reset Player.
Das ist das gleiche wie Seite neu laden, nur dass du die Seite nicht neu laden musst.
Finde ich sehr praktisch.
Org.
Hast du dein Home Assistant auf einem Raspberry Pi laufen?
Nein, habe ich nicht.
Ich habe mein Home Assistant auf einem HP Microserver Gen 8 Plus oder Gen 10 Plus.
Der letzte.
Der letzte, den es gibt.
Laufen.
Ne, asozialer Kontakt wie Offenbach Hauptbahnhof.
Leon, danke für den Sub.
Was zum Thema?
Oh, kann ich das aufmachen?
How to fit in with the Linux Community.
Ah.
Das ist ja auch schon ein Klischee, ne?
Ich meine, das kommt nicht von ungefähr.
Es gibt da sicherlich einen erhöhten Anteil solcher Leute.
Aber da sind wir ja schon weit, weit weg von.
Wo ich das hier gelesen habe.
Ich habe es erst falsch gelesen.
Irgendwie musste ich daran denken, dass ich gebannt bin auf eBay Kleinanzeigen.
Wobei, es heißt ja gar nicht mal eBay Kleinanzeigen.
Es heißt ja nur Kleinanzeigen.
Ich weiß nicht warum, aber ich bin gebannt auf eBay Kleinanzeigen.
Ich habe das nie benutzt, aber ich bin gebannt.
Moin, Michael, 5 Spilianen.
Ja, und das finde ich.
Da habe ich halt.
Oh, nee.
Ist schon wieder ausgef...
Alter, wo da vorn?
Was ist hier los?
Wo da vorn?
Mach keinen Scheiß, Alter.
That's.
Nee, ist doch überhaupt nichts.
Das ist gar nichts.
Der Chat, die baitet mich.
You got to bait it.
Ich meine, zutrauen würde ich denen, dass das wieder kaputt ist.
Wisst ihr, da hast du schon recht.
Das Problem bei mir ist, ich trinke eigentlich nie was.
Außer vielleicht schon ein bisschen was an Weihnachten und Silvester.
Aber eigentlich trinke ich nie was.
Auf solche Meetings auch nicht.
Wir hatten letztens so einen Teambuilding-Workshop.
Habe ich euch ja erzählt, dass wir im Dezember da was hatten.
Und wir hatten so ein Team-Building-Workshop.
Und da gab es auch kostenlos Essen, Trinken und so.
Und ich habe mich so krass voll gefressen.
Voll übertrieben.
Ihr wisst, wie das ist.
Leute, kostenloses Essen.
Es gibt so zwei Sachen.
All-you-can-eat-Buffet und kostenloses Essen.
Das setzt es psychologisch irgendwie, ich weiß nicht, wie man das...
Warum?
Das setzt es bei mir im Kopf aus.
Bei All-you-can-eat-Buffets muss ich mehr fressen,
als gesundheitlich und zu der jetzigen Lage angebracht ist.
Ich habe bei All-you-can-eat-Sushi schon so viel gefressen,
dass ich quasi gar nicht mehr richtig zum Bahnhof laufen konnte,
weil mir der Bauch wehgetan hat und sowas.
Ich habe, sobald es kostenloses Essen gibt, was ganz gut schmeckt,
und sobald es All-you-can-eat-Buffet gibt,
da legt sich so ein Knopf bei mir im Kopf um,
ich muss so viel fressen, wie geht.
Und das war bei diesem Teambuilding-Workshop auch.
Da gab es auch so viel zu fressen, wie geht.
Das Ding war, es gab auch so viel zu trinken, wie geht.
Und so die Leute um mich drumherum, so alle so,
oh, ein Rotwein aus der Provinz, bla bla bla,
und hier aus Italien, blablabla.
Haben wir nicht irgendein tolles...
Sekunde.
Irgendwo.
Ich kann dieses E-Mail nie verwenden.
Ich muss das jetzt benutzen.
Wo ist es denn?
Ich finde es nicht.
Hätte ich das mal ordentlich programmiert,
dann hätte ich jetzt eine Suchfunktion, die funktioniert.
Wo ist mein Wein-Teil?
Hier, nee, das meine ich nicht.
Ich habe doch den Pfeiffer, das Weinglas irgendwo.
Hier, das habe ich gesucht, alles klar.
Das habe ich gebraucht.
Ich habe eine Suche, aber die funktioniert nicht.
Guck, guck, Moment.
Wo gerade wir dabei sind, meine...
Ich sage ja immer, bei mir funktioniert immer alles first try.
Ich suche jetzt mal nach, wie heißt das, die Mode?
Two-star.
Ich suche jetzt mal, pass mal auf.
Tu es und jetzt ist es kaputt.
Es geht noch beim ersten.
Das ist seit fünf Jahren schon verbuggt, frontend-mäßig.
Die Suche funktioniert nicht.
Lässt sich bestimmt total easy fixen.
Zumindest.
Da haben wir...
Ja, habe ich damals...
Würde ich in der heutigen Zeit auch nicht mal verwenden.
Aber...
Das habe ich damals reingezogen.
Habe ich eigentlich auch nie verwendet.
Weil, ganz ehrlich, das kannst du immer eigentlich...
Eigentlich kannst du das immer nur in, ich sage mal,
unglücklichen Zusammenhängen verwenden.
Und dementsprechend...
verwende ich das immer und nicht.
Aber, um mal zu der eigentlichen Sache zurückzukommen.
Selbst dort, wo es kostenlos so viel zu futtern und zu trinken gab,
gefressen habe ich ohne Ende, ja.
Aber,
im Vergleich zu den anderen, die dann...
Ja, irgendwie Whisky sowieso.
Oder hier ein Rotwein aus der Provinz von Frankreich irgendwo.
Wisst ihr, was ich getrunken habe?
Die ganzen zwei Tage.
Ich habe eine Cola getrunken und das Rest Wasser.
Einfach nur Wasser.
Also, mit kostenlos zu trinken, kannst du mich echt nicht locken.
Ich habe nur Wasser und eine Cola getrunken.
Dafür habe ich das alles, was es zu essen gab,
habe ich in Massen reingezogen.
Reingehauen.
Wasser ist Beste.
Da muss ich nicht dein Mind changen, sehe ich auch so.
Ja, und da habe ich keinen Bock.
Dazu wollte ich eigentlich was sagen.
Und da habe ich keinen Bock, dass es erst erträglich ist,
wenn man sich vorher was reinhauen muss.
Deswegen, ich sage sowas mittlerweile eigentlich ab,
wenn ich auf solche Sachen keinen Bock habe.
Ich finde es besser, auf die Sachen, wo man Bock hat, hinzugehen.
Das ist bei mir halt nicht so viel.
Aber ansonsten sage ich da mittlerweile ab.
Neue Kubernetes-Challenge-Seite für dich.
Okay, Moment. Lass mich mal kurz gucken.
Ich muss das, ich muss ja immer...
Ups, ich bin im falschen Fenster.
Sieht gar nicht so schlecht aus. Wo hast du denn das her?
Learning Platform to Mauster.
To master Cloud Native Craft.
Cool.
Ja.
Yep, Clock.
Wir haben ja noch mehr solcher Dinger.
Ich finde es gut, dass sie zurzeit so ein bisschen aus dem Boden sprießen.
Ich mache die gerne und bringe immer guten Stream-Content.
Sekretärin war mega pisster.
Ich weiß nicht, was ich zur Weihnachtsfeier Urlaub genommen habe.
Meine Sek... Du hast eine eigene Sekretärin?
Dann bist du aber wahrscheinlich so hoch in der Hierarchie-Ebene,
dass es wahrscheinlich sogar erwartet wird, dass du auf der Weihnachtsfeier auftauchst.
Vielleicht hast du... Könnte es sein, dass du die Weihnachtsfeier sogar selbst veranstaltet hast?
Ja, dann... Also, wenn es deine Weihnachtsfeier wäre
und ich wäre deine Sekretärin, was ja in der heutigen Zeit kein Problem wäre,
dann wäre ich auch pisst,
wenn der Chef nicht selbst auf die Weihnachtsfeier kommt.
Bestimmt der CEO, ja? Seine Weihnachtsfeier.
SelfmadeEyes, danke für den Sub.
Wie empfindest du dann fachliche Gespräche auf Augenhöhe?
Kommt drauf an, um was es geht.
Also...
Es ist jetzt nicht so, dass ich wahnsinnig gerne irgendwie...
Wie nennt man das so?
Mitarbeitergespräche machen würde.
Es ist nicht so, dass ich da so wahnsinnig scharf drauf bin,
dass ich das jetzt jeden zweiten Tag bräuchte.
Aber ich finde es nicht verkehrt.
Ich finde es sogar ganz gut, dass es das gibt.
Ich mache das so, ich habe zwar keinen Bock auf diese Gespräche,
weil meistens ist das... Zumindest in der alten Firma war das so,
mal gucken, wie das jetzt in der neuen ist.
In der alten Firma ist das... Ja, im Prinzip ist das für eine Stunde angesetzt.
Nach 20 Minuten bist du eigentlich zum größten Teil durch
und dann laberst du halt random Zeug, so.
Naja, zumindest ich mache das immer so,
weil, wenn ich eine Sache damals in der Schule gelernt habe, ist,
dass es ein Fehler ist, wenn man Sachen nicht gerne macht.
Und das habe ich aus eigener Erfahrung gespürt, ja.
Wenn man Sachen nicht gerne macht, sie möglichst lange zu verdrängen
und dann möglichst unvorbereitet reinzugehen,
weil dann erfüllt sich das wieder von selbst.
Also, das muss ich anders da erzählen.
Also mal angenommen, nehmen wir mal ein konkretes Beispiel, ja.
Mal angenommen, Lehrer sagt, ey, wir haben jetzt diese fünf Themen zur Auswahl.
Jeder muss was präsentieren.
Sucht euch ein Thema aus.
Und ihr habt da überhaupt keinen Bock drauf.
So, ihr sucht euch ein Thema auf, ihr sucht euch ein Thema aus
und dann wisst ihr genau, am 25. bin ich dran
und ihr macht einfach gar nichts.
Weil ihr wisst, ihr hasst es, Sachen zu präsentieren.
Ihr habt da keinen Bock drauf und ihr verdrängt das einfach.
Und einer der Gründe, warum ihr das nicht mögt, ist,
weil es halt, ja, weil ihr auf das Thema keinen Bock habt
und weil euch das Präsentieren abfuckt und es immer scheiße läuft.
So, und ihr könnt jetzt davon ausgehen,
wenn ihr da quasi nichts macht bis zum Tag, wo es ist
oder vielleicht bis zum Tag vorher,
dann könnt ihr davon ausgehen,
dass das quasi so eine Art selbsterfüllende Prophezeiung ist.
Ihr habt keinen Bock drauf.
Oder einer der großen Gründe, warum ihr keinen Bock drauf habt,
ist, weil es immer scheiße läuft.
Aber dann könnt ihr sicher sein, dass es scheiße läuft.
Ihr sorgt quasi selbst dafür, also mit dafür, dass es scheiße läuft.
So, und deswegen ist eine Sache,
die habe ich tatsächlich in der Schule damals,
damals habe ich beispielsweise total ungern irgendwelche Präsentationen gemacht,
gelernt habe, ist, selbst wenn man keinen Bock drauf hat,
auf irgendwelche Gespräche,
es ist immer sinnvoll, sich darauf vorzubereiten,
weil sobald ihr euch darauf vorbereitet,
habt ihr einen riesen Vorteil,
weil meistens haben sich die anderen gar nicht so großartig darauf vorbereitet.
Ihr müsst euch mal überlegen, euer Chef,
euer Chef muss 20 dieser Gespräche führen.
Wie gut wird er sich auf das einzelne Gespräch vorbereitet haben,
ja, er hat sich ein paar Sachen zu euch aufgeschrieben
und sonst wie und das war's.
Also wirklich, wirklich viel Material wird er nicht haben.
Habt ihr euch jetzt aber mal, also sagen wir mal so,
euer Chef kann sich, macht sich vielleicht pro Mitarbeiter
fünf Minuten Gedanken, was er in so einem Gespräch,
was er in so einem Gespräch erzählen kann,
wenn es da wieder darum geht und gut ist.
Das heißt, ihr könnt, wenn ihr einfach mal euch eine halbe Stunde hinsetzt,
euch was überlegt und auch Sachen aufschreibt,
richtig punkten in solchen Gesprächen,
weil ihr einfach,
euch im Vorfeld schon ein bisschen Gedanken gemacht habt
und wenn ihr im Hinterkopf habt,
dass ihr vielleicht die ein oder andere Sache durchsetzen wollt,
umsetzen wollt, ändern wollt, was auch immer
und ihr euch da was Gutes für überlegt
und am besten auch den, den Fehler,
den Fehler habe ich früher, habe ich früher auch gemacht,
zumindest denke ich, dass es, dass es ein Fehler ist.
Man blendet, man blendet ja gerne unangenehme Sachen aus
und kennt ihr den Gedankengang,
dass ihr euch überlegt, okay,
da und da habe ich wieder ein unangenehmes Gespräch,
und ich würde aber gerne mal Punkt XY ansprechen,
aber in dem Moment, wo ihr euch denkt,
ich würde mal gerne Punkt XY ansprechen,
hört ihr im Hinterkopf schon quasi,
was die anderen dazu sagen werden
und ihr wisst, dass euch die Antworten abfacken
und deswegen sagt ihr Punkt XY erst gar nicht.
Hat man verstanden, was ich meine?
So, also ihr hört im Kopf quasi schon,
nennen wir es mal die Gegenargumente gegen das,
was ihr eigentlich sagen wollt.
So.
Und dadurch, dass ihr schon quasi gleich im Kopf damit rechnet,
so, oh, da gibt es wieder negativen Gegenwind,
ah, da habe ich, da habe ich ja gar keinen Bock drauf
und mach, mach das nicht,
genau an der Stelle ist eigentlich das Problem,
es ist sogar ganz gut, wenn man selbst schon drauf kommt,
was könnte denn jemand dagegen anbringen,
gegen das, was ihr sagt,
und euch schon im Vorfeld überlegen,
okay, ich weiß genau, der Typ oder der Typ,
der kommt immer mit dem gleichen Spruch auf sowas
und dann überlegt ihr euch schon im Vorfeld irgendeine,
schlüssige Antwort da drauf
oder sei es, wenn ihr einen Kollegen habt,
der immer irgendwelche zusammenhanglosen Dinge erzählen muss,
dass ihr eine gute Antwort da drauf habt,
weil spontan, es gibt Leute, die können sowas spontan,
spontan fällt euch meistens da nicht so immer das Beste ein,
das heißt, ein bisschen Vorbereitung ist wirklich gar nicht verkehrt
und das mache ich mittlerweile auch bei allen Sachen,
sei es unser Teambuilding-Workshop,
da war ich der Einzige, hat der Trainer gemeint,
ich war der Einzige, der jemals eine Themenliste
zum Teambuilding-Workshop mitgebracht hat,
und ich habe ihm halt nur gemeint,
ja gut, das ist, weil ich mir hoffe,
dass ich vielleicht auch was tut,
ich meine, was ich nicht sagen wollte, ist,
bevor wir hier einfach nur die ganze Zeit
irgendwelche blöden Spielchen machen,
können wir ja auch was Richtiges machen,
aber deswegen hatte ich eine Liste dabei,
ich habe genau einen Punkt davon ansprechen können,
und deswegen finde ich es sinnvoll,
sich im Vorfeld Gedanken zuzumachen,
und seit ich das mache,
finde ich solche Gespräche,
auch wenn sie immer gewisse Drucksituationen sind,
wenn du da sitzt, dein Chef sitzt dir gegenüber,
und er sagt, ja was können wir denn da reinschreiben,
und was denkt der davon,
es ist Blödsinn, im Vorfeld den Kopf in den Sand zu stecken
und zu warten, bis das Gespräch ist,
und dann läuft es scheiße,
am besten ist, sich wirklich Gedanken darüber machen,
okay, was sind dann meine Punkte,
was könnte der andere da drauf sagen,
und sich dann schon so ein bisschen überlegen,
okay, wie könnte man in so einem Gespräch vorgehen,
und ihr werdet feststellen,
ihr seid deutlich entspannter,
und es entsteht auch ein viel besserer Fluss,
und am Ende kommt auch was besseres raus,
also, wie gesagt, ich habe keinen Bock,
ich müsste auch nicht jeden zweiten Tag
mit meinem Chef irgendwelche Abstimmungsgespräche,
Vorstellungsdinger, Erklärtermine oder sonst was haben,
aber wenn es die gibt, finde ich die gut,
ich habe sogar bei unserem Teambuilding angesprochen,
dass ich mir wünschen würde,
dass mein Chef öfters greifbar wäre,
versus das, wie es jetzt gerade aktuell ist,
ich weiß, der kann da auch nichts für,
der hat auch keinen Bock, den ganzen Tag zu mieten,
aber bei dem ist das so,
und ich finde so Sachen mittlerweile ganz gut,
wobei das wahrscheinlich gar nicht das ist, was du meinst, oder?
Nachdem ich jetzt 20 Minuten geredet habe,
ich glaube, das ist gar nicht, was du meinst,
du meinst, du meinst, du meinst,
ähm, wenn du, wenn du, äh,
im Team oder in irgendeinem Projekt miteinander schwätzt,
über irgendwelche Technik-Sachen,
ja nö, das ist doch ganz normal,
das ist doch gut, da spricht ja nichts dagegen,
das stört mich nicht,
das, da sind auch so Dinger,
was ich nicht mag, sind so soziale Events,
wo dann über Gott und die Welt geredet wird, so,
wo ich dann erzählt kriege, wie es der Oma geht,
oder wie komisch die Leute im Urlaub drauf waren,
und sowas, das interessiert mich halt so überhaupt gar nicht,
wenn es darum geht, so nach dem Motto,
warum C++ die beste Programmiersprache ist,
da bin ich sofort für fachliche Gespräche am Start,
einfach nur zu sagen, habe den Namen vom Hardware-Rad,
Hardware-Rad, Profi-Hard, ja gut, das passt,
ja, die Sprüche, ja, ja, das, das,
das ist tatsächlich ein Wort, das kann ich mir eins zu eins,
äh, in der, in der Stimmlage von Hardware-Rad vorstellen,
bei Hardware, ich kann das nicht,
bei Hardware, Hard, Hardware-Rad,
ne, okay, bei Hardware, Hardware, sagt er immer,
bei Hardware-Rad, macht der überhaupt noch Videos,
schon ewig, ewig nichts gesehen, aber sein Shop läuft gut,
hast du da die Docker-Version, braucht man die Annons-Geschichte dringend,
was, Herr Quaid, hast du da die Docker-Version,
was, ich bin verwirrt, entweder war das eine Antwort auf was,
was ich vor drei Stunden gesagt habe,
ach, Home Assistant, Home Assistant,
nee, Home Assistant habe ich in der VM laufen,
das Home Assistant OS, Home Assistant OS als Image in KVM,
hallo, da du ja aus Frankfurt kommst,
wollte ich mal fragen, ob die Fiber One als ESP legit ist,
ich habe mit dem noch nie was zu tun,
Moment, ist Fiber One nicht dieser Code,
Moment, ist Fiber One nicht dieser komische,
Moment, Moment, Moment, Fiber One,
war das nicht dieser komische Kram, den wir letztens,
die mit kostenlos, ne, das ist was anderes, gell,
wie hieß denn diese Chat-Gel, erinnert ihr euch noch dran,
wir hatten doch letztens sowas mal, kostenloses Gigabit,
das war ein anderer, oder, Gigafiber war das,
was ist denn, was ist denn eigentlich aus denen geworden,
wo alle gesagt haben, das klingt ja sehr shady, Gigafiber,
oh, 1.0 Rezession, aha, da kam jetzt nichts mehr, oder,
das war irgendwann, äh, also, war nicht eine Klage, oder,
weiß, weiß ich nicht, habe ich nichts mehr mitbekommen,
Gigafiber, ne, zumindest, zumindest ist das halt auch was,
wo ich nie im Leben was abschließen würde,
bei MyDeals ein Video, genau das MyDeals Video haben wir gesehen,
und, vieles, vieles davon habe ich nicht gesehen,
und, vieles, vieles der Sachen, die die dort erzählt haben,
kann man sich, also, kann man sich mal ein bisschen drüber nachdenken,
auch selbst, selbst denken, aber gut, dass sie es mal gesagt haben,
ja, dass das alles sehr shady wirkt, ja, also,
aber Fiber One kenne ich nicht, habe ich mit, habe ich noch nie
was mit zu tun gehabt mit, mit, mit, mit Fiber One,
aber die haben noch ganz gute Bewertungen, keine Ahnung,
keine Ahnung, der Rübel, danke für den Sub, Abmahnung vom Verbraucherschutz,
was, ach, wirklich, wirklich, die haben mitgekriegt,
Copy Link Address, kostenlose Glasfaser,
Verbraucherschützer mahnen Gigafiber ab,
das ist das Einzige, was sie monieren, na gut,
aber mal gucken, was da rauskommt, da bin ich mal gespannt,
ob wir von denen wieder was hören, dazu weiß ich nichts,
Fiber One habe ich noch nicht, keinen, weder Kontakt mit gehabt,
noch selbst verwendet, noch kenne ich jemanden, der die verwendet,
am Montag fange ich meine erste Festanscheinung nach dem Schuljahr an,
hast du zufällig ein paar Tipps, boah, die, die nur nach 15 Sachen,
die ich immer erzähle, aber okay, naja, also, ich kenne dich nicht,
deswegen weiß ich nicht, ob du das machen würdest,
eine Sache, die mich zumindest bei neuen Azubis genervt hat früher immer,
ist, wenn die am ersten Tag gleich so wichtig getan haben,
ich weiß, du bist kein Azubi, aber ich sage, könnte ja auch sein,
wenn die am ersten Tag so wichtig getan haben, so nach dem Motto,
ach, eigentlich weiß ich das schon, ich mache das hier eh nur,
damit ich dann IHK-Zettel habe, das waren meistens die,
die am wenigsten Plan hatten, vielleicht am Anfang nicht zu sehr
auf dicke Hose machen, ansonsten generell so die üblichen Sachen,
die ich immer sage, jedes Unternehmen tickt ein bisschen anders,
die haben alle eigene Abkürzungen, eigene Bezeichnungen,
im Prinzip gibt es bei vielen Unternehmen die gleichen Strukturen,
die gleichen Abläufe, Prozesse, Vorgehen, die Dinger nennen sie bloß immer anders,
und viele Unternehmen haben einen Hang dazu, Sachen abzukürzen,
das heißt, das Beste, was du machen kannst, ist, erstmal versuchen,
ein bisschen durchzublicken, so durch das Dickicht aus neuen Sachen,
und du musst auch nicht versuchen, gleich am ersten Tag richtig durchzustarten
mit allem, es wird eh nicht klappen, je nachdem, bei welchem Unternehmen
du anfängst, kriegst du noch nicht mal einen funktionierenden Laptop am ersten Tag,
gibt dir...
Hab ich schon Dinger gesehen, teilweise, wo es eine Woche...
Also dort beim letzten Laden, wo ich gewesen bin, da hatten wir mal einen,
das war jetzt aber selbstverschuldet von dem, ja, da hatten wir mal einen,
der war über einen Monat da, der sollte sich damals, ich glaube,
der sollte sich damals um Zabbix-Monitoring kümmern, wenn ich das richtig in Erinnerung habe,
irgendwie Zabbix sollte der damals machen, und nach einem Monat oder so,
auf irgendeiner Teamrunde, hat ihn mein Chef damals gefragt, so, ja und,
wie sieht es eigentlich mit Zabbix aus?
Und da hat er ernsthaft gesagt, er muss erst noch sein Notebook einrichten.
Seit einem Monat!
Also, naja, gut, der hat danach dann aber auch nichts mit Zabbix mehr großartig gemacht.
Der hat quasi, der war dann einen Monat da, hat sein Notebook eingerichtet,
und dann war er irgendwann wieder weg.
Ja, versuche erstmal ein bisschen durchzublicken, was da wie wo läuft, ja.
Jede Firma hat, hat, tickt da ein bisschen anders, viele Sachen sind gleich,
werden bloß anders genannt, muss erst das und das machen.
Das hast du erst mal versucht rauszukriegen, okay.
Wie heißen hier spezielle Dinger?
Wo muss man hin, bei welchen Problemen?
Also, wo wendet man sich hin, wenn das Notebook nicht funktioniert?
Wo wendet man sich hin, wenn die Rufumleitung nicht funktioniert?
Welche, welche Abkürzungen hat das Zeug alles?
Und vor allem eine Sache ganz wichtig, eine Sache finde ich tatsächlich nicht unwichtig,
da habe ich auch schon negative Erfahrungen gemacht,
weil es gibt Leute, die tun ganz gerne so, als wären sie der, der Macker,
und der, der das Sagen hat, sind es aber gar nicht.
Wenn du es nicht weißt, direkt, wer dir was zu sagen hat, frag deinen Chef,
den du ja hoffentlich am ersten Tag, der dich am ersten Tag abholt oder sowas,
frag, wer dir was zu sagen hat.
Vielleicht nicht so direkt, so nach dem Motto, ey, Alter, hier, wie sieht's aus?
Wer ist wer?
Aber das ist nicht, das ist nicht schlecht zu wissen.
Wer hat dir was zu sagen?
Also, wer kann dir nicht, wer hat dir, wer kann dir Aufträge geben
und wer kann dir was sagen, was du, wenn, dass du, dass du was machen musst, ja?
Aufträge geben ist ja relativ normal, dass es von allen, von allen kommt,
aber die nach dem Motto, das musst du jetzt machen vor dem anderen, wer darf das?
Und wenn der, wenn dein Chef sagt, der Einzige, der dir hier irgendwas beauftragen kann, bin ich,
dann weißt du schon gleich, ey, wenn irgendjemand um die Ecke kommt und sagt,
das Ticket ist jetzt Priorität Nummer eins,
du denkst aber nicht, dass das Priorität Nummer eins ist,
dann kannst du gleich sagen, ja, äh, wenn du denkst, dass das Priorität eins ist,
geh zu meinem Chef.
Also, zu wissen, wer einem was zu sagen hat, ist echt nicht unwichtig.
Das heißt nicht, dass man sich super am ersten Tag, versteht mich jetzt nicht falsch,
ich will damit nicht sagen, dass man schon am ersten Tag hier auf super unkooperativ machen soll,
so nach dem Motto, ich mach nix, bevor du zu meinem Chef gehst.
So ist das nicht gemeint, oder?
Ich hoffe, das hat man nicht so verstanden.
Ich weiß nur, dass man erstmal so prinzipiell klärt, wer ist, also nicht nur wer dein Chef ist,
sondern wer dir Aufträge, kann ja auch sein, dass du in irgendeinem Projekt bist,
wo du dann Projektleiter hast, dir was sagen kannst, so einfach abcheckst, okay,
wer kann dir Anweisungen geben, die du dann befolgen musst, selbst wenn du nicht willst.
Man kann Aufträge geben, kann dir viel, aber wenn du dann sagst, nö, find ich nicht wichtig, ist okay,
aber wenn dein Chef sagt, hier, mach mal, dann kann er halt auch, ist er an der Stelle, wo er es sagen darf.
Hat man verstanden, was ich meine?
Wie gesagt, ich meine nicht, dass man sich am Anfang gleich quer stellen sollte.
Versuchen, mal einen guten Eindruck zu machen, am Anfang ist nie verkehrt, erster Eindruck zählt oftmals.
SelfmadeEyes, danke für den Sub.
Ach ja, pro Gruppe eine Sekretärin, ach so, okay.
Okay.
Hab schon gedacht, das war deine Weihnachtsfeier.
Max kann mich seit heute Nachmittag nicht mehr auf meine Remote-Linux-Kiste per SSH einloggen.
Schlecht.
Sadge.
Immer Access denied, trotz korrektem User und Passwort, kann das Linux...
Naja, die Passwörter laufen ab, je nachdem, was du gesetzt hast.
Wobei das eigentlich normalerweise nicht der Fall ist.
Aber du kannst das machen, gerade für normale User.
Kannst das machen, dass die Passwörter ablaufen.
Oder logst dich.
Oder logst du dich per Key ein.
Ne, mit korrektem User und Passwort kann das ein Linux-Problem sein.
Achso, Moment, das ist ein Public-Server.
Also wenn das ein Public-Server ist, dann ist das theoretisch möglich.
Da würde ich mir erstmal Gedanken drüber machen, wie einfach war mein Passwort zu erraten.
Und wenn es ein Remote-Server ist, dann ist das kein Problem, da kannst du nämlich über deine Admin-Konsole, wo auch immer du bist, bei welchem Hosting-Anbieter,
kannst du per Admin-Konsole auf deinen Linux-Server drauf.
Und du kannst den Linux-Server rebooten über die Admin-Konsole und dann per Root, im Boot-Menü, per Root-Root-Shell starten.
Das geht.
Je nach Betriebssystem geht das ein bisschen anders.
Bei manchen musst du gleich init gleich bin bash reinschreiben.
Bei manchen musst du 1 reinschreiben.
Bei manchen musst du s reinschreiben.
Aber du kannst dein System über die Admin, über die Admin-Konsole...
kannst du rebooten mit einer Root-Shell und auf das System zugreifen.
Das funktioniert.
Ansonsten kannst du das Ding sicherlich immer noch mit einem Image starten, mit irgendeinem ISO-Image.
Aber wenn du Remote-PSSH nicht mehr drankommst, ist die Admin-Konsole bei deinem Hosting-Anbieter wahrscheinlich das einzige, was du machen kannst.
Ja ne, das stört mich nicht.
Also wenn es um konkrete Sachen geht, da kann ich auch mit den Leuten...
Guck mal, Leute, bei mir ist das so, immer wenn es um so random Zeug geht, was mich dann interessiert,
dann habe ich so Probleme oder dann nerven mich so soziale Interaktionen.
Ich kann beispielsweise ohne Probleme 5 Stunden am Stück, 7, 8 Stunden am Stück mit Leuten im Discord hocken, wenn wir MMO-Kreisel-Crime machen.
PvP oder irgendwelches PvE-Zeug oder so, überhaupt kein Problem.
Und da sind die übelsten random Leute dabei.
Da sind Deutsche dabei, sind Franzosen dabei, sind Engländer, sind Niederländer dabei.
Alle möglichen Leute sind dabei.
Und alle stammeln sich da auf Englisch ein bisschen was bei zurecht.
Wobei man ehrlich sagen muss...
Umso öfters man das übt und man sich so in der jeweiligen Fachsprache bewegt, dann geht das ganz gut.
Also Englisch auf IT-Ebene funktioniert mittlerweile ganz gut und Englisch im Gaming-Sektor funktioniert mittlerweile auch ganz gut.
Funktioniert zumindest gut genug, dass ich auf der Gamescom auf Englisch durchgekommen bin.
Funktioniert auch gut genug, dass ich auf der Arbeit mit Leuten aus Spanien oder...
Wo kam der Typ von der Telekom her aus?
Bulgarien oder so?
Das funktioniert.
Wo ich Probleme habe, wenn es um englische Sachen geht, sind dann irgendwelche...
Also einmal irgendwelche Dialekte.
Da steige ich komplett aus.
Wenn die dann irgendwelche Dialekten schwätzen, habe ich das Gefühl, die verstehen sich selbst nicht.
Ist aber auch ein bisschen, sagen wir mal, bei deutschen Dialekten auch nicht viel anders.
Aber da verstehst du gar nichts.
Und...
Ja, wenn es halt...
Wenn es dann halt so spezifisch...
Wenn es dann halt so spezifische Sachen sind, so...
Also ich meine, ich könnte...
Ich könnte wahrscheinlich durchaus in England einkaufen gehen und da was finden.
Aber mich über irgendwelche aktuellen Ereignisse des jeweiligen Zeitgeschehens da unterhalten...
Da vielleicht auch ein bisschen...
Aber da wird es dann schon schwierig.
Da wird es schwierig.
Und eines habe ich gemerkt.
Es macht enorm viel aus, ob man im Fluss ist oder nicht, was das angeht.
Also wenn ich beispielsweise jetzt...
Ein paar Tage am Stück mit den Leuten, die wir aus Spanien auf der Arbeit haben, rede.
Im Teams.
Auf Englisch.
Einen ganzen Tag.
Dann geht das so.
Da fängt man dann auch irgendwann an, so ein bisschen Themen abseits zu beschwätzen.
Ja.
Zum Beispiel wollte ich den einen Spanier schon die ganze Zeit mal fragen, ob er eigentlich
El Risitas kennt.
Das ist...
Ich weiß, übelste random Frage.
Aber ich wollte einfach mal checken, wie bekannt ist der Typ eigentlich in Spanien.
You know El Risitas?
Ja.
El Risitas.
Muss ich ihn mal fragen.
Dann geht das eigentlich ganz gut.
Aber wenn man dann ein paar Tage wieder raus ist, dann ist er erstmal holprig.
Eigentlich schon für den Sub.
Hast du immer noch nicht gefragt?
Nee.
Kostenlos zu haben, wenn man da drauf steht.
Weiß.
Wir haben AKW...
Nicht AKW.
AKV als Abkürzung.
Okay.
Ja.
Wir hatten mal...
Wie habe ich...
Wie hieß das nochmal?
Moment.
ADS hatten wir mal.
ADS als Abkürzung.
Leute.
Wenn ihr ADS hört...
Oder AD.
Aber ADS hieß es eigentlich.
Was heißt das für euch?
Was versteht ihr unter ADS?
Also sagen wir mal zumindest die...
Die...
Die meiste.
Also ADS...
Manche würden da Ads drunter verstehen.
Also Werbung.
Mancher versteht Aim Downside.
Ja.
ADS Datenbank von SAP gibt es auch.
Also die meisten Leute würden...
Die ich kenne.
Verstehen Active...
Genau.
Tote.
Genau Totem.
Gut, dass es einer sagt.
Die meisten Leute die ich kenne.
Die verstehen da drunter wahrscheinlich Active Directory Services.
Aber nicht so bei uns im alten Laden wo ich gearbeitet habe.
Da war das der Antrags Dispatcher Service.
Hieß das.
Und nachdem ADS schon 500 verschiedene Bedeutungen hat, hat das auch die Leute immer extrem verwirrt.
Wenn da einer so...
So wie...
Wie...
Wie so überzeugt von jeder weiß es doch immer erzählt hat.
Ja ok.
Da haben wir eine Fehlermeldung im ADS bekommen.
Und die Leute, die halt neu waren, die haben sich halt gedacht, ja ADS könnte auch Außendienst bla bla bla irgendwas heißen. Und die Leute, die da nicht so oft dabei waren, die haben da rausgehört, okay, sie haben wieder eine Fehlermeldung im Active Directory Service gehabt.
Und das Fatale bei solchen doppelten Abkürzungen ist, wenn du denkst, es macht Sinn, dann glaubst du auch, dass es so ist. Also wenn du keine Ahnung davon hast, dass das der Antrags-Dispatcher-Service ist und du hörst Fehler im ADS, dann du denkst dir dann, aha, Fehler im Active Directory, habe ich verstanden, abgehakt.
Du hast immer im Hinterkopf, ey, die haben doch gerade Fehler im Active Directory. Dabei meinte der was ganz was anderes. Ja, mir gefällt mein Notebook, was ich von der aktuellen Arbeit halt auch nehme.
Wobei, das Notebook ist nice, gegen das Notebook sage ich gar nicht, die Windows-Installation geht mir auf den Sack. Das ist ohne Mist der einzige, im Vergleich zum alten Laden, im Vergleich zum neuen, dort wo ich jetzt arbeite, der einzig positive Punkt vom alten Arbeitgeber versus dem neuen.
Dort konnte ich Linux auf mein Notebook installieren. Beim neuen kann ich das nicht. Beim neuen habe ich so eine komische Linux-VM.
Glücklicherweise, auf der ich auch das meiste machen kann, was ich will. Aber ohne die konnte ich gar nicht arbeiten.
Ich habe einen Windows-Notebook. Es ist so abfuck, Alter. Du wisst ja, was das Gute ist, morgen ist Freitag.
Ja, vielleicht hat dir mein Geschwätz ja ein bisschen was geholfen.
Das erinnert mich an jemand, der hatte so einen Standardspruch, das erinnert mich an jemand aus der alten Arbeit.
Und zwar?
Dass du gesagt hast, also, selbst wenn du nicht, es gibt ja viele Leute, so muss ich das sagen, es gibt ja viele Leute, die haben Probleme damit, wenn sie sagen, und oftmals auch zu Recht, wenn sie sagen, das ist so und so, und du sagst, ne, das ist falsch.
Da haben die ein Problem damit. Verstehe ich auch, weil du willst nicht einfach vor einen Latz geknallt kriegen, ne, das ist falsch.
Du willst ja vielleicht auch hören, sag mal, bist du dir sicher? Ich habe letztens gelesen, dass es da jetzt das und das gibt.
So.
Da muss das ein bisschen halbwegs sinnvoll verpacken und dann geht das auch.
Aber wir hatten auf der Arbeit jemand, auf der alten Arbeit hatten wir jemand, da lief das immer so.
Der hat gesagt, so, ich sage jetzt mal irgendwie so ein random Thema.
Der hat gesagt, Playstation Network bei der PS3 war besser als Xbox Live.
So, da habe ich ihm gesagt, naja, sicherlich unterschiedliche Geschmackssache, aber...
Also, fiktive, ähm, Konversation, ja.
Aber ich sehe das nicht so.
Guck mal, du musst beispielsweise fürs PSN nichts bezahlen, aber Xbox Live hat Partys und so.
Also ich finde nicht, dass das das Bessere ist.
Xbox Live ist aus meiner Sicht eindeutig besser.
Und dann hat der als Antwort gebracht, das war immer seine Standardantwort.
Nein, das kann nicht sein, da habe ich andere Informationen.
Das war seine fucking Standardantwort auf alles.
Das kann nicht sein, da habe ich andere...
Das kann nicht sein, da habe ich andere Informationen.
Und wenn er dann gefragt hat, ja, was hast du denn für Informationen, hat er gesagt, das habe ich doch gerade gesagt.
Das war immer, das war immer die gleiche, immer die gleiche dumme Diskussion, Alter.
Ja, da habe ich andere Informationen.
Ja, und, welche sind das?
Ja, habe ich doch gerade gesagt.
Das ist das Prinzip, im Prinzip warst du dann wieder bei der Ausgangssituation, wo du sagen musstest, ja, aber ich habe dir doch gerade gesagt, dass die nicht stimmen.
Ja, da habe ich aber andere Informationen.
Ja, und welche?
Habe ich doch gerade gesagt, ja, aber die stimmen nicht.
Aber da habe ich wieder andere Informationen.
Du bist eine Endlosschleife, ja?
Endlosschleife.
Konntest du nicht gewinnen.
War vorbei.
Ja, da habe ich...
Das war immer der Standard, immer der Standard im Spruch, Alter.
Also, wir hatten, muss ich echt sagen, wir hatten auf der alten Arbeit schon echt nervige Leute, die dann auch in so Positionen waren, wo man sich immer gedacht hat, wie kommen die da hin?
Ich kann mich noch an...
Ich kann mich noch an unseren Change Manager erinnern.
Der keinen Bock hatte, Changes zu managen und sowas.
Das war eh das Geilste.
Ja, dann kümmer dich doch drum.
Ja, nee, das musst du machen.
Ja, aber du bist doch der Change Manager.
Okay, ich will jetzt nicht so hart flamen.
Ich war da lange.
Ich fand es da lange Zeit auch gut.
Hat sich in den letzten Jahren ein bisschen zum Negativen entwickelt.
Um es jetzt nicht gar so positiv darzustellen.
Es gibt bei der neuen Arbeit auch Leute, wo ich mir so denke, Alter, ihr geht mir teilweise schon ein bisschen auf den Keks.
Werden die sich umgedreht auch denken.
Ist ja auch überhaupt nichts Wildes bei.
Aber bei dem letzten Land hatten wir schon echt so ein paar Spezialisten in der Richtung.
Im jetzigen Team habe ich jemanden, der muss immer um alles Mögliche diskutieren.
Muss immer gucken, dass man das so ein bisschen umschifft.
Aber, ey, wo kämen wir da hin, wenn das wirklich alles immer super reibungslos und harmonisch und ohne Probleme abläuft?
Das ist nirgendwo so.
Wenn du irgendwo 15 Leute auf einem Haufen hast oder ich weiß gar nicht, wie viele wir sind.
Da ist das...
Du kannst nicht, und das kann... Muss man sich auch abschminken.
Du kannst nicht bei 15 Leuten erwarten, dass jeder mit jedem super klarkommt.
Das funktioniert nicht.
Wichtig ist, dass die Leute insoweit...
Halbwegs...
Ähm...
Ja, kompetent genug sind...
Die Sachen auch mal gut sein zu lassen.
Ja, dass man das nicht übertreibt.
Man weiß, okay, mit dem und dem komme ich nicht so hundertprozentig klar.
Da gibt es immer Reibereien und Probleme.
Dass man sich ein bisschen müde macht.
Dass man sich ein bisschen Mühe gibt, dass das...
Die Sachen zu umschiffen.
Ja, man muss es ja nicht immer drauf anlegen.
Und dann kommt man auch wunderbar miteinander aus.
Gibt aber Leute, die müssen halt immer aus Prinzip da Diskussionen anfangen.
Ich gebe mir Mühe, auch wenn ich nicht so die krassesten Social Skills habe.
Ich gebe mir Mühe, mit allen soweit gut klar zu kommen, dass das auf fachlicher Ebene und Arbeitsebene gut funktioniert.
Und...
Ja, mit denen verstehe ich mich besser.
Mit denen schwätze ich dann auch mal im Teams ein bisschen privates Zeug.
Den Rest muss ja nicht.
Ich meine, wir arbeiten zusammen.
Wir fahren nicht zusammen in Urlaub.
Mein Windows ist gerade random abgekackt.
Ja, das kommt vor.
Aber selten, muss man echt sagen.
In letzter Zeit, also in den letzten Jahren über schon sehr selten.
Browser crasht.
Ich konnte danach keine Ahnung...
F.
Also insgesamt muss man sagen,
wenn man das mal vergleicht mit Windows 98, ME und dem ganzen Shit von damals,
ist Windows mittlerweile doch schon erstaunlich stabil.
Wann hattet ihr, jetzt mal gefragt Chat,
wann hattet ihr euren letzten Windows-Crash?
So richtig Plus-Screen und...
Einer der üblichen...
Achso, und Chatge,
Übertaktungsversuche nicht mit reinrechnen.
Das ist das Ding bei Übertaktung.
Sowohl GPU-technisch, Grafikkarten-technisch.
RAM.
Gerade RAM ist sehr anfällig bei Übertaktungen für...
Wir machen mal einen Plus-Screen.
Das ist natürlich klar.
Also wenn du die Sachen außerhalb der Spezifikation betreibst
und dann auch teilweise
deutlich außerhalb der Spezifikation...
Da musst du dich nicht wundern.
Vor einem Jahr?
Undervolten, genau. Ja, sowas meine ich jetzt nicht.
Ja, random Bugs habe ich unter Windows auch.
Ich meine, das ist wirklich ein Crash.
Ja, random, sinnlose random Bugs habe ich unter Windows auch.
Ich bin mir immer noch nicht sicher, ob das ein Bug ist,
dass mein VM,
wenn er hier unten so ein komisches Ding anzeigt,
das sollte er normalerweise eigentlich gar nicht.
Ja, ich bin auch kein Windows-Fan,
das weißt du.
Deswegen machen wir eigentlich fast alles
unter Linux, wenn wir was basteln.
Also, sobald wir Technik-Krams machen,
bin ich immer in der Linux-Kiste unterwegs.
Übrigens, Fun Fact,
Moment, Moment, erzähle ich euch gleich.
Ich muss erst mal den Chat aufholen, sonst wird das nichts.
Ja, ja, hast schon recht.
Du hast recht. Meine...
meine Interessen sind aber halt nicht sonderlich breit gefächert.
Ich interessiere mich für ein paar Sachen
und dafür dann halt richtig.
Und wenn ich mit was anfange, was mich interessiert,
dann interessiert mich das auch immer richtig.
Aber du hast insofern recht.
Letztens erst in der...
inzwischen zwei Meetings
mit einem eine Viertelstunde
geschwätzt auf der Arbeit.
Wir sind im gleichen Raum sitzen geblieben,
eine Meeting war fertig, nächste, nächste Meeting war im gleichen Raum.
Mit einem geschwätzt
eine Viertelstunde, mit dem ich quasi noch nie
großartig längere Zeit
geredet habe.
Und worüber haben wir uns unterhalten?
Über Rennen und Fahrradfahren.
Konnte ich früher nicht mitreden.
Mittlerweile zumindest
rudimentär.
Da hat er dann auch erzählt,
so seine Zeit, da habe ich dann die...
die Garmin-App rausgeholt,
hab dem meine Zeiten gezeigt,
dann hat er sein Handy rausgeholt und hat gesagt,
benutzt Strava, was sonst?
Die ganzen coolen Leute sind auf Strava.
Also,
es kann durchaus helfen,
allgemeine,
allgemeingültige Sachen im Hinterkopf
zu haben, wenn man Smalltalk betreiben muss.
Aber das Ding ist halt,
ich habe da einfach keinen Bock drauf.
Das nervt mich, diese 0815 Smalltalk-Sachen,
wenn es um Sachen geht, die mich nicht jucken.
Zum Beispiel,
bestes Beispiel ist so und
frohes neues Jahr und
wie war Silvester bei dir?
Was hast du gemacht? Erzähl mal und
wie lief's da?
Ich hab keinen Bock's zu erzählen.
Ich will's auch nicht wissen.
Das stresst mich immer.
Du hast dir doch gerade selbst
geantwortet.
Du bekommst für die Arbeit
einen Notebook, hast keinen Desktop-Rechner, korrekt.
Also ein ziemlich fettes
Notebook, also
von Hardware-Ausstattung.
Es hat 32 GB RAM.
Was ist denn so ein aktueller? Ich weiß gar nicht, wie viele
Core ist, ehrlich gesagt. Wahrscheinlich 16
mit Hyper-Threading.
Inklusive Hyper-Threading. Wahrscheinlich 8
und 16 mit Hyper-Threading.
Das ist gar nicht schlecht, das Notebook.
Leider total verhunzt, was die
Windows-Installation angeht.
Nein. Nein, nein, nein.
Bei uns ist hier Versicherung,
Compliance und Überprüfung und
nee, nee, nee, da kann nicht jeder was. Ich kann auf meiner
VM glücklicherweise installieren, was ich will.
Das sind keine T14, das sind keine
IBM, beziehungsweise
Lenovo, nicht IBM.
Tja, da hab ich keine Erfahrung mit.
Ich kenn nur die Updates unter, unter
MacOS, äh, nicht MacOS, iOS.
Und die dauern
teilweise richtig lang.
Gerade auf älteren iPads ist es teilweise
10, 15 Minuten am updaten.
Ich hab übrigens gelesen,
dieses Jahr, sie sollen die Storage-
Preise richtig anziehen.
Und wisst ihr, was das erste ist,
was passieren wird, wenn die Storage-Preise anziehen?
Da kommt Apple um die Ecke
und sagt, ja Moment, also so
32 GB mehr
Flash-Speicher in so einem iPhone,
ja, das muss schon mal 400 Euro
Aufpreis kosten.
Oder mit irgendwie sowas kommen die da um die Ecke.
Die Flash-Aufpreise
für Smartphones sind eh
jenseits von gut und böse.
Die sind durch nichts gerechtfertigt eigentlich.
Zumal selbst die kleinste Ausstattung,
zumindest mir,
komplett ausreicht.
Ich wollte euch irgendwas
erzählen. Ach ja,
Fun Fact, was passiert,
wenn auf Meetings über Security-Probleme
diskutiert wird.
Einer Tag, wo ich da war,
war ein Projekt,
Projekt-Status-Meeting
und da waren nicht viele
da, dachte ich.
Kamen dann aber doch relativ viele
rein, anscheinend waren die alle wieder da.
So waren wir dann am Ende doch 10 Leute.
Normalerweise sind es noch ein bisschen mehr, aber
waren immerhin. Erste Woche des Jahres
war schon relativ viel da.
Kam rein, so.
Und da kam einer von unseren Security-Leuten
und meint hier, guckt mal, ich zeige euch
mal was.
Top, sowas zu machen.
Ich zeige euch mal was und da hat er so ein Dashboard gezeigt
von einem
Image-Scanner.
Man wusste nicht, dass es ein Image-Scanner war,
ich wusste, dass es ein Image-Scanner ist.
Ihr kennt das vielleicht, es gibt Tools,
die können Container-Images scannen
und je nachdem, was die
finden in diesen Container-Images,
können die sagen, ob das, was im Container-Image
drin gefunden wurde, in der
Version aktuell Sicherheitslücken
aufweist. Kennt ihr sowas?
Wisst ihr, was ich meine?
Das kenne ich jetzt zum Beispiel nicht.
Ja, ja, genau, genau sowas.
Genau sowas
meine ich. Ja, korrekt.
Trivi, sowas in der Richtung meine ich.
Sowas in der Richtung meine ich.
Da kannst du deine Container-Images
mit scannen lassen
und da kriegst du
dann so eine Liste raus, was da
ne, nicht wirklich,
was da drin gefunden wurde. Genau sowas
hier in der Richtung. So.
Und der hatte
das kenne ich, das kenne ich,
aber sowas hier meine ich. So.
Und er hatte so eine Liste mit,
der hat unsere Container-Images, die
für das Projekt dort
vorhanden sind, die Images gescannt
und hatte da eine Liste mit
Security-Problemen.
So.
Und von diesen Problemen hatten, keine Ahnung,
30 oder so
waren als
Critical gekennzeichnet.
Da hat er das einfach mal so unkommentiert
in den Raum gestellt
und die Leute dann erstmal so
Was ist hier los?
Und schon, hast schon die ersten Leute gesehen
so nach dem Motto, die Hacker
klopfen schon an die Tür, so nach dem Motto
Datenbank-Dump ist schon im
Darknet hochgeladen, so.
Haben die sich schon gedacht in ihrem Kopf.
Übelst Panik.
Muss halt dazu sagen,
die meisten Leute, die da hocken,
die haben halt nicht wirklich
Ahnung gehabt, was sie da sehen.
Und ich hab sie dann versucht zu beruhigen,
das hat nicht so ganz
nicht so ganz funktioniert.
Ja.
Es hat nicht so ganz funktioniert.
Ich hab gesagt hier, Leute, also
genießt das mal mit einer
Portion Skepsis. Das ist ein
Imagescanner, der scannt das komplette
Container-Image und guckt nach.
Das heißt noch lange nicht, dass das,
was er da drinnen findet, überhaupt irgendwo
verwendet wird, noch
dass das von außen irgendwie
ausnutzbar wäre.
Ja. Zumal das eine Ding
hat, ein Webfrontend, das ist eh nur intern
erreichbar. Also selbst wenn
die es verwenden, die Chance, dass es jemand
ausnutzen könnte, sind wirklich äußerst
gering. Also mal keine Panik,
am Freitag hab ich einen Termin mit
dem Security-Mensch
von uns. Da gucken wir uns das an.
Zumal es eh alles Images sind,
die wir von externen Anbietern
kriegen. Also wir können die Images ja auch selbst
gar nicht fixen ohne riesen Aufwand.
Also macht euch mal nicht so viele Gedanken.
Es hat nichts gebracht.
Ich hab's ein paar Mal
versucht, aber
nach diesem Intro haben die alle Panik
geschoben. Und der eine meinte
schon sowas wie, wir müssen aufpassen.
Wir müssen aufpassen, dass das nicht im nächsten
Management-Meeting
zur Sprache kommt.
Weil wenn die da sehen, 145
hohe Security-Probleme,
dann schalten sie uns alles ab.
Die haben möglichst Panik geschoben.
Naja. Ja haben
wir. Wir haben aber wahrscheinlich so ziemlich
das, ich sag den Namen nicht, weil
ich mir nicht sicher bin, ob wir nicht die einzigen sind, die
das gekauft haben. Wir haben so ziemlich das weirdste
und exotischste System
ever gekauft. Wahrscheinlich,
weil die eine gute Sales-Abteilung haben und sonst
nix. Ja und eines
und eines der
der Sachen
in diesem Report war,
da stand drinne, es wurde
Pearl gefunden. Und in
der Pearl-Version gibt es
eine kritische Sicherheitslücke,
mit CVE-Score
keine Ahnung,
9.3 oder sowas.
Oh, Pearl
und Pearl darf doch hier gar nicht verwendet
werden, ist doch so alt.
Leute, das ist...
Die haben in ihrem Container-Image
irgendwann halt Pearl
installiert. Das wird für nix verwendet, es ist einfach
nur da. Keine Panik,
es ist einfach nur da. Das Image ist nicht gut
gebaut, okay, ja, das
verstehe ich, aber
Pearl lädt nicht unsere Daten,
da geht's Darknet hoch.
Da hat irgendeiner beim Imagebauen
kein gescheites Base-Image
verwendet oder eben
ein standardvolles
Debian-Image oder sonst was, da ist ja glaube ich auch
immer noch Pearl dabei.
Ja, und das ist... Ja, das bisschen
das Problem, das haben sie
bei uns auch, ja, weil irgendjemand mal
entschieden hat, das muss bewertet werden.
Ich finde es im Prinzip
ja nicht verkehrt, das zu bewerten,
aber das muss bei offensichtlichen
Sachen schnell abgefackelt werden können.
Wenn du sagst, okay,
Pearl, Pearl, Pearl,
davon 30 Fehler,
wir wissen genau, Pearl ist da einfach
nur installiert, der Hersteller sagt selbst,
wird für nix verwendet, abgehakt. 30 Stück,
zack.
So muss das gehen, dann ist das handelbar.
Wenn du jeden Furz einzeln
bewerten musst, obwohl es 30 mal Pearl
ist, wo man weiß, dann machst
du nix anderes mehr. Das ist auch
wieder so ein Ding, wo ich mir gedacht habe, Mensch, manchmal,
manchmal ist es glaube ich gar
nicht so gut, im großen
ja, in der
großen Runde
sowas
als Dashboard dahin
zu klatschen, da schieben sie wieder Panik.
Ich wette mit euch, ich habe morgen
früh Termin
mit unserem Security-Experte dazu,
oder Security-Team,
da habe ich Termin
mit dem zu und ich wette,
alle Images
sind Drittanbieter-Images
und alle Fehler
in diesen Images sind wahrscheinlich
einfach nur schlecht gebaute Images
und alle vielleicht nicht,
95%, ein paar Sachen
werden vielleicht wirklich eine gewisse
Substanz haben,
weil letztendlich,
überlegt euch mal, selbst
wenn ihr eine top-aktuelle Software habt,
die
einfach nur ein paar Wochen alt ist, wenn ihr Pech
habt, irgendwo von irgendeiner
Dependency der Dependency
der Dependency, so ein paar Sicherheitslücken
gibt es immer.
Die findest du immer.
In irgendwelchen Dependencies.
Aber wenn man die sich dann genauer
anguckt, sind die ja meistens so total
...
... ...
wieder witzig, wo ich mir gedacht
habe, so einer ist,
übertreibt es halt, übertreibt es halt nicht.
Wisst ihr was, übrigens,
das ist auch so ein Ding, was mich
in der IT schon längere
Zeit so ein bisschen wurmt, ist,
es wird auf der einen
Seite sehr viel Wert gelegt
auf, ich muss
das jetzt richtig sagen, ich
wollte nämlich gerade sagen, sehr viel Wert gelegt auf Security
und das ist ja eigentlich nicht das, was ich sagen will.
Das ist ja auch nicht falsch.
Es wird sehr viel Wert
so meine ich das, es wird sehr
viel Wert oder es wird zu viel
Wert auf
offensichtliche Sachen gelegt
und die werden so
kompliziert gemacht, dass
offensichtliche Sachen enorm viel
Zeit fressen, die aber
meistens gar nicht die großen
Probleme oder die
großen Lücken verursachen.
Das ist scheiße formuliert.
Nicht die großen Lücken verursachen,
die eigentlichen Leaks
verursachen. Weil
wenn es so Entscheidungen gibt, wie zum
Beispiel hier was, was Menschheit schreibt,
dass jetzt jeder, auch wenn
es offensichtlich zu was gehört,
was nicht benutzt wird,
jeder Change von irgendwie
einem Typ bewertet
werden muss, von einem Typ
reviewed werden muss, von einem anderen Typ nochmal
abgenommen werden muss, dann hast du
ein halbes Team,
was sich eine Woche lang um
30 Security-Probleme kümmert,
die sehr, sehr, sehr
wahrscheinlich nie irgendein
Problem verursachen werden,
weil das einfach nur drinnen ist, nirgendwo
aufgerufen wird und nicht mal verwendet wird.
Im Umkehrschluss
die Sachen, die ein bisschen komplizierter
sind, die nicht so offensichtlich
mit einem 40. Scan gefunden werden,
tja,
die bleiben liegen.
Da macht sich keiner Gedanken drum.
Das kenne ich nicht.
Ja gut, du hast ein Tool,
ein Tool löst das Problem aber nicht.
Wenn du
Vorschriften hast,
wenn du Vorschriften hast,
dass das trotzdem jedes Einzel
geprüft werden muss, obwohl man eigentlich schon weiß, dass das
höchstwahrscheinlich nichts macht
und dementsprechend man
gar keine
dass man zu sehr den offensichtlichen
Sachen hinterher rennt.
Nehmen wir mal
ein Beispiel.
Du hast einen Raum
mit einer Tür und einem Fenster.
Und es gibt jetzt
die Ansage,
Türen müssen
immer verschlossen und maximal
abgesichert sein.
Und dann
schließt sie die Tür ab. Dann kommt das erste
Security Review und sagt, ha Moment,
das Schloss ist aber nicht sicher genug.
Okay, wird das Schloss ausgetauscht.
Kommt das nächste Security Review und sagt, ah,
das Material, aus dem
die Tür ist, ist nicht ganz richtig.
Neue Tür eingebaut, Security Review,
nächstes Security Review, ah,
also wenn man da mit dem Bulldozer dagegen fährt,
dann reißt das ein an der Wand
und es muss verstärkt werden.
Wird die Tür verstärkt. Nächste Security Review,
ja, aber hier, wenn da irgendwie
einer mit der Rakete drauf schießt und
ihr wisst, was ich meine. Und dann artet das immer aus,
wo keiner dran denkt, ist, dass der Raum
ein Fenster hat im Erdgeschoss.
Das sieht halt der Prozess nicht vor.
Oder das sieht
die Vorgaben nicht vor.
Und das ist ja
oftmal, wenn ihr euch
manchmal die,
wie heißt das immer so,
diese Postmortem
Sachen anguckt,
die nach Datenleaks veröffentlicht wird,
das ist oftmals total
simpler Shit,
wodurch das zustande kommt, ja.
Von Entwicklern, die
ihren USB-Stick
verloren haben, von
weggeworfenen Laptops,
von irgendwelchen offenen
WLANs, von irgendwelchen
Google Drive Shares,
wo alle Leute
Zugriff drauf haben. Das sind teilweise
super simple, einfache Sachen.
Die haben das auf der einen Seite
super krass vernagelt,
aber das Datenbank-Admin-Passwort,
das muss natürlich im Klartext
über Google Drive geshared werden, weil wie soll man es
dann doch sonst machen?
Ist jetzt natürlich nur ein Beispiel, aber ihr wisst, was ich meine.
Ich,
ja, nehmen wir mal
was anderes.
Beim alten Arbeitgeber hatten wir einmal
so einen Security-Vorfall,
der
ein bisschen brisanter gewesen ist,
und zwar
letztendlich wurde dort auch
alles, also ich meine, ich kann es euch nicht so sehr im Detail
erzählen, aber grob, im Prinzip
wurde da auch alles abgesichert, ja.
Logins
wurden protokolliert,
du konntest dich teilweise gar nicht mehr
direkt netzwerktechnisch verbinden,
du konntest,
also es war super,
super krass secure mit vernagelt.
Und wisst ihr, was am Ende passiert ist?
Wie es dazu gekommen ist,
dass sie sich
Ransomware-Shit für Windows-Kram eingefangen haben?
Es ist dazu gekommen,
wie gesagt, alles, alles
super abgesichert,
und was ist passiert?
Sie hatten einen, jetzt haltet euch fest,
sie hatten einen Windows,
wahrscheinlich 2008
oder so, was das noch da, oder 2012,
was da drauf gelaufen ist,
SFTP-Server,
wo eine
externe Werbeagentur,
immer irgendwelche Sachen drüber eingeliefert hat.
Diese Werbeagentur
wurde gehackermant,
und dort haben die
dann festgestellt, ach gucke mal da,
von hier haben wir ja Zugriff
drauf, auf einen uralten
Windows-SFTP-Server.
So, und
ich bin mir nicht ganz sicher, wie es
weiterging, ich,
wenn ich es wüsste, würde ich es euch
auch nicht genau sagen.
Zumindest dort,
auf dem sftp server haben sie dann relativ schnell irgendein altes ungesicherten account im active
directory gefunden der ist erst sftp outdated ich glaube da war noch gar nicht das sftp auf windows
läuft zumindest im endeffekt lief es dann darauf raus dass du über die software verteilung vom
active directory keylogger und und passwort ram ram damper verteilt hast verteilt wurden wohlgemerkt
nur auf windows notebooks ich war glücklicherweise nicht betroffen also das ist der typische fall von
alles super vernagelt so vernagelt dass man gar nicht mehr richtig arbeiten konnte aber das war
kein problem und wisst ihr warum das kein problem war das ist jetzt aber spekulation von mir das ist
das ist jetzt aber spekulation von mir das ist jetzt aber spekulation von mir das ist das ist
das ist jetzt spekulation von mir aber ich bin mir relativ sicher dass das so ist wisst ihr warum
das kein problem war weil man gesagt hat das ist ja kein problem wir haben ja einen vertrag mit dem
dienstleister dass die schon alles richtig machen das passiert nämlich total oft dass man solche
solche solche vergessen wie sich das nennt solche solche compliance verträge also heißt das glaube
ich also solche verträge macht mit seinen dienstleistern was die alles einhalten müssen
die netzwerke waren
getrennt aber die konnten darauf zu greifen weil ihr sachen ein liefern mussten dass man solche
solche verträge macht die dienstleister drin steht ja wie die und diese vorgaben haben wir
das dazu kann ich nix nix im detail erzählen damit man nämlich finden wo ich vorher gearbeitet habe
und die sind diese vorgaben müsst ihr euch halten und so was natürlich sagen klein wenn es war eine
kleine werbeagentur klitsche die sagen zu allem jahr und abend ja bei der bank zu denen kommt sagt
war bei einer Bank beim letzten Arbeitgeber, wenn eine Bank zu denen kommt und sagt, ey, Werbeagentur, das und das müsst ihr erfüllen, dann sagt die Werbeagentur, aber selbstverständlich erfüllen wir das alles, die denken sich dann so nach dem Motto, ey, wisst ihr was, scheiß drauf, wir brauchen den Auftrag und wenn es in die Hose geht, sind wir eh am Arsch, so, das denken die sich dann und insofern war das dann halt für einen Arsch und wisst ihr, wie das Ganze aufgefallen ist,
das ist ja noch viel witziger gewesen, wie das Ganze aufgefallen ist, es ist nicht aufgefallen etwa durch irgendwelche tollen Security AI Scanner oder was, hast du nicht gesehen, nein, es ist daran aufgefallen, dass jemand sein entschlüsseltes, müsst ihr euch mal vorstellen, seine entschlüsselten Keypass Passwörter in einer Textdatei auf einem Windows Laufwerk gefunden hat und da hat er sich dann gedacht, glücklicherweise war der so schlau damals,
hat es gecheckt, hat es gesagt, also meine Keypass Passwörter gehören nicht im Klartext auf dem Windows Share und da hat er dann gesagt, sag mal Leute, wie kommen die denn da hin und dann sind sie erst darauf gekommen, dass es da Probleme gibt und wisst ihr, was das Gute war, wisst ihr, was das Gute war, wir mit unseren Linux Systemen und Linux Notebooks waren komplett raus, wir hatten die einzigen Server und die einzigen Rechner, Clients, also Admin Systeme,
die sicher waren in dieser Zeit, es ging dann so weit, dass sogar kurzfristig haben wir Ubuntu USB Sticks für alle angefertigt, also für alle, die mussten, Ubuntu USB Sticks und die mussten dann alle von den Ubuntu USB Sticks booten, leider hat das nicht so lange gehalten, leider hat es nicht so lange gehalten und wisst ihr, was die Konsequenz daraus war, die das Management abgeleitet hat,
die Konsequenz ist so, wir, ich habe es euch schon erzählt, so wir, dass ihr mir das nicht
glauben werdet. Aber die Konsequenz
daraus, die man abgeleitet hat, ist
Windows Defender
auf allen Servern zu installieren, inklusive
Linux. Damit sowas nicht mehr
vorkommen kann.
Das ist kein Witz.
1 zu 1. Oh, sorry,
nicht Windows Defender, Microsoft
Advanced Threat Protection
nennt sich das. Das ist Windows Defender.
Die haben sich daraus abgeleitet,
weil
das kacke konfiguriert war und Windows shit,
dass auf allen Servern, inklusive
Linux, Windows Defender installiert werden muss.
Und das Ding hat so krasse Probleme
gemacht, nachdem es drauf war.
Laufen hat es irgendeinen shit.
Und das Beste ist an Windows Defender,
Microsoft kann
Windows Defender Updates ausrollen,
Virensignaturen
Updates ausrollen, die eigentlich
die Defender Updates sind.
Du musst ja Microsoft erlauben,
damit es funktioniert.
Du musst
ja für den Windows Defender Virensignaturen
Updates verteilen, beziehungsweise
freischalten, dass die sich bei Microsoft abrufen.
Ich weiß gar nicht, wie es genau funktioniert.
Zumindest muss das Ding sich regelmäßig
Windows Defender
Virensignaturen Updates ziehen.
Und Microsoft verpackt
in Virensignaturen, nicht nur
Virensignaturen, sondern
Windows Defender Updates.
Und so kam es dann auf einmal,
dass es Linux File Server gab,
die immer 5% CPU Last
hatten, nix wildes. Und auf einmal
sind die immer auf 95%
CPU Last gelaufen. Kam dann raus,
ach so, ja,
die letzte Virensignature enthielte
ein Windows Defender Update. Das hat einen kleinen
Bug, das verursacht jetzt halt unter Linux super viel
CPU Last. So ein
Schrott, Alter.
Das ist halt wieder der typische
Fall von blindem
Aktionismus gewesen.
Das
passiert ja oftmals.
Umso zugenagelter
was ist, umso abpackender
es ist zu arbeiten,
umso mehr werden Wege gesucht,
es zu umgehen.
Das habe ich irgendwie aus Versehen hier gerade das
kleiner gemacht.
Bestes Beispiel dafür ist doch
Passwortrichtlinien. Wenn es
Passwortrichtlinien gibt, das
Passwort muss mindestens
Stellen lang sein, mindestens ein
Sonderzeichen enthalten, mindestens eine
Zahl und das und das.
Das wird dann so kompliziert,
dass die Leute sich das nicht mehr merken können.
Was machen die Leute dann? Die Leute
machen dann sowas hier. Guckt.
Sowas kommt dann als Passwort raus.
Sorry, sorry.
Groß, groß, groß und Kleinschreibung.
Ja, da kommt dann sowas als Passwort
raus.
Weil ja gut, erfüllt die Passwort
Richtlinien.
Kann man sich gerade noch so merken.
Übertriebene Passwort Richtlinien sorgen
für genau so einen Blödsinn.
Wie bist du hergekommen über YouTube oder auf
der Twitch Empfehlung?
Hier in der Hecken Heck, Heck
Beck Edition, okay?
Kann man sagen, gucken, aber nicht
jetzt.
Vielleicht das da auch viel Geld.
Ist das das richtige?
Komm, wir gucken aber nicht. Jetzt ist zu
lange, weil das in Schlotte Stunde Talk.
Wenn ich, wenn ich mir ne Stunde
mal vergessen wie die heißt.
Wo es Musse quasi
eine Challenge ist, ein Passwort
zu finden, das den immer komplexer,
wirkenden, problematischen!
werden, wenn Anforderungen genügt. Wie hieß das denn?
Passwort.
Passwort Game. Ne, keine Ahnung.
Wisst ihr, was gut ist, Leute?
Morgen
ist Freitag.
Morgen nehme ich was auf, morgen Mittag.
Kann ich Samstag
hochladen? Dann müssen wir
endlich am Wochenende mal ein bisschen Technikzeug
streamsen wieder. Ich hatte einfach
keine Gehirnkapazität in letzter Zeit.
Morgen ist Read Only
Friday. Wirklich, Passwort Game.
Ja, das
meine ich. Genau, das meine ich.
Please choose a password.
1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6. Okay.
Erstes
Rule. Must include
special character.
Digits
in your password must add
up to 25.
Kannst du dann sowas machen wie irgendwie
aber die Digits.
Ich kann jetzt nicht einfach machen
23. Also muss ich jetzt.
Boah, das ist halt.
Krasses Zeug. Ja, das meinte ich
genau. Was ist Read
Only Friday?
Tatlab? Aber das freut mich,
dass es morgen Freitag ist.
Dann gibt es wieder
Bream Video und MMO Kreiselgrind.
Read Only Friday,
dass es keine Changes gibt. Ja, das ist eine gute Idee.
In dem letzten Laden, wo ich gearbeitet habe,
gab es tatsächlich nie Changes am Freitag.
Weil die nicht
wollten, dass dann was ist. Was echt
eine sinnvolle Policy war, fand ich.
Finde ich.
Naja. Gut, Leute.
Es ist jetzt gleich
Bad Kid Time. 22 Uhr.
Ihr wisst, Boomer werden
früher müde.
Aber Boomer brauchen zum Glück nicht so viel Schlaf.
Deswegen gehe ich jetzt pennen.
Morgen bin ich kurz vor sieben
wieder am Start. Allerdings nicht
auf Twitch.
Sondern auf der Arbeit.
Remote. Homeoffice
das Beste. Und dann Nachmittag.
Nachmittag wahrscheinlich
streamen oder
ich nehme erstes Video auf
oder umgedreht. Mal gucken.
Michael, 5 Spieljahren.
Schön, dass du da warst.
Ich habe dich lange nicht im Stream gesehen.
Oder ich habe einfach nicht richtig hingeguckt.
Letzten schon gefragt. Wo ist er denn?
Und wo ich mich auch gefragt habe, ist
Wo ist denn eigentlich in letzter Zeit
der Chainlore?
Nicht, dass der temporär gebannt ist
oder so wieder.
Kann ja bei ihm immer sein.
Den habe ich auch schon eine Weile nicht mehr gesehen.
Chat. Kann das sein?
Das wir komplett
mod
modlos
waren. Der Max war am Anfang mal da.
Habe ich gesehen.
Ah, da ist er. Ne, waren wir nicht.
Max ist wahrscheinlich immer noch da.
Modcheck.
Es fehlen einige.
Ne, die fehlen mir nicht, weil
der Chainlore spammt manchmal auch
sehr fragwürdige ASCII-Dinger, wo man ihn dann
timeouten muss für.
Modcheck fehlgeschlagen.
Verstehst du?
Ist zur Verfügung.
Zurzeit sehe ich nicht, dass wir mehr
Mods brauchen.
Und es ist gut zu wissen,
wenn wir neue Mods
brauchen, mache ich das meistens so,
dass ich im Mod-
Channel im Discord frage,
wen sich die anderen Modgis
gut als Modgift vorstellen können.
Du bist ja auch schon relativ aktiv
hier. Ich meine 565 Messages.
Einfach den ganzen Chat
zum Mod machen. FyFet.
Das Gegenteil. Das ist Inverted-FyFet.
Einmal pro Stream.
Es geht gar nicht darum, ob ich das erlauben will
oder nicht. Wenn ihr irgendwelche komischen
Ihr wisst, was Zeug postet.
Kann ich das nicht einfach
stehen lassen.
Der Chainlore hat schon
Gachi-Roll-ASCII-Dinger
gepostet, wo man deutlich mehr gesehen hat.
Mit der Taktik kommst du bei mir nicht
weit. Das ist die Taktik, die ich früher teilweise
auch mal verfolgt habe. So nach dem Motto,
wenn man was werden wollte, hat man besonders
offensiv gesagt, dass man das gar nicht werden will.
Und dann...
Aber das ist dann keine gute Taktik.
Ich bin sogar mal
in der Grundschule mit dieser Taktik
fast Klassensprecher geworden.
Ich weiß nicht, was mich
geritten hat, dass ich mich da wählen
lassen wollte zum Klassensprecher.
Und...
Ich hab die Taktik gefahren.
Weiß ich noch. Da läng geblieben.
Ich hab die Taktik gefahren so nach dem Motto,
ich würde das ja voll gut machen, aber ich will
sowas gar nicht machen.
Wer will dann sowas machen? Wer will dann
Klassensprecher sein? Da muss man sich dann um Sachen kümmern.
Ich will das überhaupt nicht machen. Ich könnte das
sicherlich ganz gut machen.
Aber ich will das gar nicht.
Und dann wäre ich fast Klassensprecher geworden.
Zum Glück bin
ich es nicht geworden.
Alles klar, Leute. Wir sehen uns.
Bis denn.
Bis morgen Mittag.
Macht's gut. See you.